Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und auch heute gibt es wieder eine neue Ausgabe hier in unserer nicht abreißen wollenden Gesprächsserie rund um die Raumfahrt, in der wir schon so einige Aspekte vorgestellt haben, vor allem sehr viele Projekte, die sich so außerhalb und im Orbit befunden haben. Heute wollen wir mal einen ganz anderen Aspekt der Raumfahrt-Forschung vorstellen, der sich nicht ganz so weit in den Weltraum vorwagt, aber nicht weniger wichtig ist. Konkret geht es hier um das Projekt SOFIA, das Stratosphären-Observatorium für Infrarot-Astronomie. Aus dem schönen Vorteil hat, dass es sich auf Deutsch und auf Englisch genauso abkürzt, nämlich SOFIA. Und um darüber kenntnisreiche Auskunft zu erhalten, begrüße ich Alois Himmes. Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Danke Pritlove, danke liebe Hörer.
Ja, ihres Zeichens wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter im DLR hier am Standort in Bonn, wo ich das erste Mal hier in dieser Serie bin. Aber nebenbei auch Projektleiter des SOFIA-Projektes, richtig?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, Stratosphären-Observatorium für Infrarot-Astronomie. Das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal ein langes Ding. Konkret verbirgt sich dahinter ein Flugzeug tatsächlich, was mit einem Teleskop ausgestattet ist. Das ist ja eigentlich was Ungewöhnliches, oder?
Das ist in der Tat ungewöhnlich. Es ist allerdings nicht das erste Mal, dass es so etwas gibt, sondern es basiert auf Vorgängermodellen. Der Grund, warum man ein Flugzeug für astronomische Forschung verwendet, ist der, dass das Flugzeug in Höhen oberhalb des Wasserdampfes, der örtischen Atmosphäre, fliegen kann. Und dass man mit einem Teleskop, was an Bord ist, dann die Infrarot-Strahlung im Weltall messen kann. Das kann man natürlich auch mit Satelliten machen und sogar noch deutlich besser, weil die halt völlig aus der Atmosphäre raus sind und im Weltall auch das Teleskop selber sehr kalt gekühlt werden kann und damit die eigene Wärmestrahlung nicht störend auf die Wärmestrahlung der astronomischen Objekte wirkt, die man beobachten möchte. Aber mit SOFIA ist man schon so hoch, dass eben dieser Wasserdampf, der auf der Erdoberfläche fast sämtliche Infrarotstrahlung blockiert, die kommt also gar nicht bis auf den Erdboden. Und selbst in hochgelegenen Observatorien, in schilenischen Annen oder auf Hawaii, mit vier Kilometern ist immer noch Wasserdampf da, der viele Linien absorbiert. Und man hat also einen sehr verwaschenen, verschwurmenden Blick ins Weltall in diesen Höhen. Ja, warum geht man da nicht gleich ins Weltall? Wenn es da doch noch besser ist, das ist einmal eine Kostenfrage. Es ist sehr viel teurer, so ein Observatorien im Weltall. Wenn es cryogen, also auf absolut niedriger Temperaturen mit flüssigem Helium, gekühlt wird, muss man das so machen, dass dieses Helium langsam verdampft. Und nach drei, vier Jahren ist der Heliumvorrat verbraucht. Und dann sind diese Observatorien im Weltall in der Regel nutzlos. Sie sind auch heutzutage weit vom Erdorbit entfernt, lassen sich also nicht warten und wieder füllen mit diesen cryogenen Kühlmitteln. Das Hubble-Space-Teleskop ist ein klassisches Beispiel dafür, wie man Weltraum-Observatorien auch warten und auch verbessern kann und neue Instrumente hochbringen kann. Aber das Folge-Observatorium, das James Webb, was die NASA gerade entwickelt mit einem 6-Meter-Spiegel, wird also in einem weit entfernten Orbit von der Erde sein und ist also dann nicht mehr zugänglich. Und zu einer Wartungsmission mit dem Shuttle hat man sehr schnell eine halbe Milliarde an Dollar zusammen. Das heißt, Weltraum-Observatorien haben eine lange Vorlaufzeit auch und sind begrenzt von der Zeit her einsetzbar, während SOFIA angedacht ist, über einen Zeitraum von 20 Jahren Wissenschaft zu machen. Und es landet nach jeder Beobachtung am frühen Morgen wieder, kann gewartet werden, man kann die Instrumente wechseln und man kann vor allen Dingen auch immer allerneueste Instrumente alle paar Jahre anbringen, sodass man immer auf dem neuesten Stand der Detektertechnologie ist.
Das heißt, die Idee hier ist, eigentlich so eine Art Kompromiss zu finden, aus dem optimalen Standort, der natürlich erstrebenswert ist, weil klar, umso toller, desto toller. Aber auf der anderen Seite steigt der Preis auch mit jedem Meter, den man weiter von der Erde weg sein möchte, eben durch diese genannten Gründe, also Initialkosten, Planungskosten, Transportkosten, Wartungskosten etc. Und auch immer mit dieser Gefahr, dass es sich irgendwann halt gar nicht mehr tragen lässt und dann einfach weg ist. Dann muss man halt einfach mal die Anzahl der Tage, die es gelaufen ist, teilen durch die Kosten und dann wird es teuer.
Das sollte ich gleich am Anfang sagen. SOFIA ist nicht billig in dem Sinne. Es ist auch schon sehr teuer, weil gerade auch heutzutage die Kerosinkosten, haben wir gesehen, sind extrem gestiegen. Also wir hatten zu Beginn des Projekts noch mit einem Dollar pro Galone an Treibstoffkosten gerechnet. Mittlerweile sind es drei, dreieinhalb manchmal. Also man braucht schon eine große Betriebsmannschaft am Boden, um so ein Flugzeug ständig zu warten und auch regelmäßig zu fliegen. Also es ist deutlich teurer als ein bodengebundenes Teleskop. Das ist auf jeden Fall so. Und es ist in der Tat ein Kompromiss zwischen den bodengebundenen Teleskopen, die eben nur eine begrenzte Sicht ins Weltall haben, weil dieirdische Atmosphäre doch sehr stark viele Bereiche ablockt. Und den Weltraum-Observatorien. Der wesentliche Aspekt, denke ich, sind gar nicht mal, dass es sehr viel preiswerter ist als ein... Es ist preiswerter, aber nicht sehr viel preiswerter als ein Weltraum-Observatorium. Insbesondere ein Weltraum-Observatorium kann, wenn es weit genug von der Erde weg ist, 24 Stunden rund um die Uhr beobachten. Mit SOFIA können sie 10 Stunden in der Nacht fliegen und dann müssen sie wieder landen und sie können nicht jeden Tag fliegen. Also das ist... Man kommt auf vielleicht 1000 Wissenschaftsstunden pro Jahr in der Endausbaustufe, wenn alles mal perfekt funktioniert. Und da sind Weltraum-Observatorien deutlich... haben deutlich mehr Beobachtungszeit. Aber wie Eingang schon erwähnt, oft sind sie eben nach drei, vier Jahren tot und können nicht mehr genutzt werden. Und dann ist diese schöne Investition im Weltall... Perdue. Und der eigentliche Vorteil bei SOFIA ist, dass man wirklich neue, neu entwickelte Technologien und Wissenschaftler sind ja immer sehr schnell damit, noch einen besseren Detektor, noch einen besseren CCD-Ship zu entwickeln. Man sieht ja diese Entwicklung bei den Kameras, CCD-Kameras, die es heutzutage gibt, wie schnell es da immer wieder neue Modelle gibt. Und die kann ich sehr schnell nach drei, vier Jahren Entwicklungszeit auf SOFIA einsetzen. Bei einem Soliden brauche ich 15 Jahre oder so was.
Na, das heißt, man ist einfach näher am technologischen Fortschritt.
Richtig, man ist näher am technologischen Fortschritt. Man kann die allerneuesten Detektoren einsetzen. Das Beispiel zurzeit fliegt das Herschl-Observatorium, der ESA. Das ist von der Konzeption her vergleichbar mit SOFIA. Es beobachtet auch im infrarot- und sogenannten Submillimeterbereich. Das ist für drei Jahre angelegt. Das sieht auch so aus, als wenn das Kühlmittel genau diese drei Jahre hält. Das hat aber Instrumente an Bord, die durchaus vergleichbar sind mit denen, die bei SOFIA jetzt an Bord sind. Aber die jetzt bei SOFIA an Bord sind, sind einfach zehn Jahre fortschrittlicher oder fünf Jahre fortschrittlicher schon. Und gleichen dadurch zum Teil die immer noch etwas schlechteren Bedingungen in der Atmosphäre schon wieder aus, weil sie einfach entweder eine größere Bildfläche haben oder mehr Pixel. Sie kennen das von den CCDs, die ersten CCD-Kameras hatten, weiß ich nicht, 100.000 Pixel. Dann war es eine Million, jetzt ist man bei 5, 8. Und so geht auch die Entwicklung im Infrarot-Bereich weiter.
Beziehungsweise auch generell in der Elektronik. Wir sind ja immer noch in einer sehr dynamischen Phase der technologischen Entwicklung überhaupt, und das macht an der Stelle nicht... Bevor wir jetzt vielleicht weiter ins Detail gehen, würde ich das ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen von hinten aufrollen und mich in die Frage ran tasten, warum macht man das eigentlich überhaupt? Und bevor wir das vielleicht machen, auch noch mal so ein bisschen die Frage, was ist denn so Ihr Weg überhaupt so in diesen Bereich, also mit welcher Grundausbildung sind wir beim DLR gelandet?
Ja, das war nicht von Kindheit angeplant, wie in den seltenen Fällen. Ich komme vom platten Land, wo der Begriff DLR und so weiter kein Thema war. Ich bin aber quasi indirekt mit Flugzeugen groß geworden, da ich in der Nähe eines Militärflughafens der britischen Rhein-Armee aufgewachsen bin und quasi mein erstes Motorengeräusch war ein Düsen-Triebwerk, irgendwann Mitte der 50er-Jahre und hatte dann also immer Interesse eigentlich für die Luftfahrt und weniger für die Raumfahrt und hab dann auch während meiner Gymnasialzeit hatte ich die Möglichkeit, die letzten drei Jahre auf einem naturwissenschaftlichen Zweig zu verbringen, also Naturwissenschaften haben mich dann immer interessiert und hab nach dem Abitur dann aber nicht jetzt als Ingenieur, Luft- und Raumfahrtingenieur oder Maschinenbauer oder sonst was in der Richtung studiert, sondern mich hat dann auch zu den Flugzeugen, man guckt mal zum Himmel und wenn es dann dunkel wird, sieht man dann die Sterne, also mich hat die Astronomie immer sehr früh fasziniert als Kind schon und da Da hab ich gedacht, ja, das muss ich auch studieren. Und man macht sich dann wenig Gedanken, wie man das später beruflich verwerten kann. Also hab dann nach dem Abitur dann hier in Bonn Physik und Astronomie studiert. Und ja, man hat irgendwie, man denkt ja, vielleicht kann man auch im Universitätsbetrieb oder Max-Planck-Gesellschaft irgendwo im Institut unterkommen und kann diese Forschung ewig weitermachen. Aber es gibt natürlich sehr viel mehr Studenten als nachher stellenfrei sind. Und gerade in den 70er-Jahren war es so, dass viele Stellen schon besetzt waren, anders zum Teil als heute. Und vielleicht war ich auch nicht schlau genug, um halt die wissenschaftliche Karriere fortzusetzen. Und dann irgendwann muss man auch an seine Familie denken, schauen, wie man Geld verdient, sodass ich dann Mitte 86 hier beim DLR gelandet bin. Das war eigentlich auch ein Zufall. Also es gab zwischen Köln und Bonn, wo man studiert, und Köln-Ports, wo das DLR ist, immer Verbindungen. Und einer von meinen Professoren hatte auch Projekte über das DLR, wo er mit Höhenforschungsraketen gearbeitet hat. Und da kam dann der Kontakt zustande. Und dann war da eine Stelle frei, da habe ich mich beworben und wurde dann da auch genommen. Das heißt, meine erste Aufgabe war, im Bereich mit Höhenforschungsraketen zu arbeiten. Höhenforschungsraketen sind Raketen, die zum Beispiel in den skandinavischen Ländern am Polarkreis gestartet werden. Zwischen 100 und 1000 Kilometer hoch fliegen, ihre Beobachtung machen und dann wieder runterfallen. Entweder ins Wasser, wo sie verschwinden, oder am Fallschirm, wo die Instrumente geborgen werden können. Das ist also auch so ein Bereich, wo man sehr schnell die wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse hat. Also eine sehr schöne Gelegenheit eigentlich für Doktoranden, Diplomaten, dort mitzuarbeiten. Also es gibt viele Doktorarbeiten in dem Bereich, wo die Doktorarbeit wird, das Instrument entwickelt, gebaut, man fliegt mit der Höhlenforschungsrakete, am nächsten Tag hat man die wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse, man werdet sie auspubliciert.
Das ist sehr schnell. Das ist sehr schnell.
Das ist der Hintergrund, weil die eine der Zielrichtungen, zum Beispiel die Polarlichter sind, die dort auftreten. Und der andere Hintergrund ist, man ist weit weg von bevölkerten Gebieten. Da gibt es Riesengebiete, die sind leer und da kann man Raketen schießen. Also im Zweiten Weltkrieg hat man auch in Peenemünde Raketen geschossen, das glaube ich nicht, dass das heute noch funktionieren würde. Es werden nicht so viele Touristen und das würde also nicht gehen. Es gibt andere Startplätze, für die diese Raketen sind, mitten in der australischen Wüste oder oft auch an Küstenstreifen gelegen, wo man aufs Meer hinausschießt und da stört das eigentlich auch keinen. Die Schifffahrt wird gewarnt, aber sie können ja mal versuchen, mit so einer Rakete ein Schiff zu treffen. Das ist aussichtslos. Ja, das war mein Hintergrund, wie ich zum DLR gekommen bin. Aber schon gleich in der ersten Woche, also mein eigentliches Aufgabengebiet, für das ich eingestellt wurde, waren diese Zuwendung, die Betreuung von Wissenschaftlern, das Geld, was die brauchen, um ihre Instrumente zu entwickeln, im Höhenforschungsraketenbereich. Aber gleich in der ersten Woche hatte mein damaliger Chef mir einen dünnen Aktenordner auf den Tisch geknallt. Da stand SOFIA drauf und er sagte, ja, Himmes, Sie sind Astronomen, Sie wissen, was das ist. Wir haben gerade angefangen, hier eine Kooperation mit NASA aufzubauen, das ist auch was für Sie. Und ich wusste natürlich überhaupt nicht, was das war. Und aus diesem dünnen Aktenordner von, weiß ich nicht, 100 Seiten, sind inzwischen mehrere Tonnen Papier. Ich glaube, wir haben mehr Papier in jedem Raumfahrtprojekt wird.
Und mehrere Tonnen Metall vor allem, weil das Ding existiert ja jetzt mittlerweile auch.
Das existiert, aber es wird in der Regel mehr Gewicht an Papier produziert, als an Hardware.
Ein Missverhältnis.
Trotz moderner Computer und so weiter.
Das Papierlose Büro hat auch in der Astronomie noch nicht Einzug gehalten. Gut, aber warum Infrarot?
Warum Infrarot? Also die moderne Astronomie ist ja von den frühen Anfängen. Da hat man Sterne beobachtet, wo sie stehen und hat im Optischen beobachtet, wie das Licht auf die Erde kommt, hat man in seine spektralen Bestandteile zerlegt. Ich denke, die meisten Hörer wissen, dass weißes Licht eigentlich nicht gibt, sondern dass es sich aus vielen Regenbogenspektren zusammensetzt und dass sich…
Das, was man halt sieht, wenn der Regenbogen in Folge des Aufbrechens durch die Wassertropfen das wieder zeigt.
Ja, und dann kommt noch hinzu, dass bestimmte Elemente und Moleküle im Weltall auch bestimmte Linien aussenden, ganz schmalbandige Linien, die sich als schwarze Streifen quasi in diesem Regenbogen dann zeigen und die sehr charakteristisch sind für ein bestimmtes Molekül, für einen bestimmten Rotationsübergang eines Moleküls.
Also schwarze Streifen, weil eine Absorption vorliegt. Das heißt, das Licht trifft mehr oder weniger gleichmäßig verteilt auf und das Material, die Masse, nimmt einfach bestimmte Bereiche raus. Und wenn man das dann halt misst, dann sieht man, was es ist.
Das Sonnenlicht, was aus dem Sonneninneren kommt, trifft z.B. in der Atmosphäre der Sonne auf Eisenatome oder auch ionisierte Eisenatome und die absorbieren einen Teil dieses Lichtes, so dass es abgeschwächt wird und sich deswegen als schwarzer Streifen im Spektrum sichtbar wird, weil das Licht ist weg. Es kommt eben nicht mehr an. Es ist in dem Eisen absorbiert. Umgekehrt gibt es auch Emissionslinien, also Linien, die, wenn ein Atommolekül selber was abstrahlt, dann sehe ich das als helle Linie. Also das ist immer, habe ich Hintergrundstrahlung und Elemente davor, dann wird das Licht blockiert und ich sehe, das Licht, was fehlt, kann nur deswegen fehlen, weil ein bestimmtes Atom im Vordergrund steht und es absorbiert. Oder ich sehe starke Emissionslinien, die sich eben als sehr helles Wand in einem Spektrum zeigen. Diese Information kommt auf der Erde eben nur im Optischen an, das was wir auch im Visuellen mit dem Auge sehen. Und es hat sich dann sehr schnell oder nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg eigentlich gezeigt, nachdem man Röntgen-Technologien entwickelt hat oder im Zweiten Weltkrieg hat man diese Radartechnologie zu militärischen Zwecken halt entwickelt und man hat dann festgestellt, dass dort auch Störgeräusche aus dem Weltall kommen. Da hat man gesagt, Störgeräusche müssen wir unterdrücken. Aber sehr schnell waren dann die Astronomen dabei und haben gesagt, das sind ja gar keine Störgeräusche, da kommt irgendwas aus dem Weltall, das müssen wir untersuchen. Also der Radiobereich war eigentlich derjenige Bereich, wo man glaube ich am ehesten gesehen hat, dass es Sterne und Galaxien und Staubwolken eben nicht nur im optischen Photon aussenden, sondern auch im Radiobereich. Und dann hatte man die ersten kleineren Höhenforschungsraketen hochgeschickt, die so 100, 150 Kilometer hoch gingen, und die haben dann auch Röntgenstrahlung gemessen, die aus dem Weltall kam. Also dann war eigentlich klar, dass diese astronomischen Objekte, Sterne, Sonnenplaneten, Molekülwolken, Galaxien, in einem breiten Spektrum abstrahlen, das weit über das menschliche Auge hinausgeht. Und in diesen anderen Spektralbereichen noch sehr, sehr viel mehr Informationen sind, als wenn wir nur das Optische betrachten. Das heißt, die moderne Astronomie ist eine Breitbandastronomie. Sie können heutzutage selten noch Fortschritte erzielen, indem sie nur in einem Weltall im Bereich schauen. Sondern man nimmt dann die Daten von Röntgen-Observatoren, die nur im Weltall funktionieren, Infrarot, Optisch, Radiobereich, Teilchenstrahlung, und versucht, ein Gesamtbild davon zu bekommen. Ihre Frage war speziell nach dem Infrarot. Infrarot ist Wärmestrahlung, die eben auch nicht bis auf den Erdboden vordringt, wohl nur zum geringen Teil. Da hat sich gezeigt, dass gerade in den Gebieten, in denen Sterne neu entstehen, das heutige Verständnis ist so, dass das Weltall vor ca. 13 bis 15 Milliarden durch den berühmten Urknall, dass es der Thürie entstanden ist und nach anfänglichen Phase eben nur aus Wasserstoff und Helium bestand, sich dort erste Sterne gebildet haben und in diesen Sternen dann nukleare Prozesse ablaufen, wie in einem Kernreaktor. Und während dieses Prozesses andere Atome entstehen, andere Elemente entstehen, wie Sauerstoff, Kohlensstoff, Stickstoff, bis hin zu Eisen und dass am Ende der Lebenszeit eines solchen Sterns, wenn er groß genug ist und als Supernova explodiert, dann auch die über das Eisen hinausgehenden Elemente in dieser Explosion gebildet werden, wie zum Beispiel Uran, Blei, Gold, Silber.
Also ohne Supernova kein Gold.
Ohne Supernova kein Gold und ohne Supernova und Sternentstehung auch keine Menschen, kein Leben. Weil nur aus Wasserstoff und Helium können sie uns nicht zusammenbauen. Wir brauchen im Wesentlichen Kohlenstoff, Stickstoff, Sauerstoff und noch etliches andere. Und ja, das hat sich dann gezeigt, dass diese explodierenden Sterne dieses Material auswerfen, was sich mit dem ursprünglichen Material vermischt und dann Staub, Gas, Molekül, Wolken bildet, so richtig dreckige Wolken. Wenn die so über Raffinerien schauen, da passiert ähnliches. Diese Molekülwolken, die strahlen einen Großteil ihrer Energie eben im Infrarotbereich ab. Das hat mit ihrer Temperatur zu tun, mit den Vorgängen, die sich dort abspielen. Und wenn sie mit einem optischen Gerät auf so eine Molekülwolke schauen, schauen sie auf die Oberfläche. Und wenn sie im Infrarotbereich reinschauen, können sie sehr viel tiefer reinschauen. Das hat damit zu tun, wenn die Objekte, die sie beobachten, in der gleichen Größenordnung liegen, wie die Wellenlänge, mit der sie beobachten, dann wird dieses Licht absorbiert. Wenn aber die Wellenlänge größer ist als die Objekte, die sie beobachten wollen, also kleine Staubmoleküle und ihre Wellenlänge ist größer, dann können sie an denen sozusagen vorbeischauen, immer tiefer reinschauen. Und je langwelliger das Infrarot ist, umso tiefer können sie in solche Molekülwolken reinschauen bis tief in den Kern, wo vielleicht der eigentliche Prozess der Sternentstehung gerade begonnen hat. Das heißt, am Anfang, wenn dort im Zentrum ein Stern entsteht, ist die ehemalige Molekülwolke noch als Konkon um dieses neu entstehende Sternen-Tornetengebiet drum rum. Und die Strahlung dieser Sterne kommt noch gar nicht durch. Das heißt, erst wenn der Stern wirklich sein thermonukleares Brennen begonnen hat und sich sozusagen durchbrennt durch seine ehemalige Höhle, dann sieht man das auch im Optischen.
Das heißt, versteht ihr das richtig, also Infrarot ist quasi ideal, um jetzt in diese, in die Wolken reinzuschauen, in denen sich Sterne erst entwickeln. Aber in dem Moment, wo sie dann wirklich anfangen zu brennen, dann kann man jetzt auch nicht in den Stern hineinschauen, oder?
In den Sternen, der ist dann, die Oberfläche ist so heiß, das ist dann wie die Sonne. Sie können bis auf die Oberfläche schauen, sie können die Sonne im Röntgenbereich beobachten, dann sehen sie aber auch nur ganz wenig, also nur bis auf die Oberfläche, weil das dann sofort absorbiert wird. Das ist eine Röntgenstrahlung, die sie beim Arzt bekommen. Es ist ja so, dass sich das medizinische Personal und sie selber auch durch Blei abschirmen. Das geht also sehr schnell, dass das dann nicht durchkommt.
Und warum ist das so interessant, in diese Sternentstehungswolken reinzuschauen?
Die Astronomen möchten verstehen, wie dieser ganze Prozess abläuft. Im Groben ist es heutzutage relativ klar, wie das vonstattengeht. Man hat diese riesen Molekülwolken, die sich in einer Mischung aus schon verbrauchten Sternen, aus explodierten Sternen, aus Staub und Gas zusammensetzen. Sie sind natürlich nach astronomischen Maßstäben relativ dicht. Nach menschlichen Maßstäben sind sie unglaublich dünn, aber eben sehr groß. Die Theorie ist, dass sich diese Molekülwolken entweder unter ihrem Eigengewicht gravitativ langsam zusammenziehen und dichter werden, oder durch eine Supernova-Explosion in der Nachbarschaft, durch den Gasdruck dieser Explosion, den Schock, den diese Explosion auslösen, auch angestoßen wird, zusammengedrückt zu werden. Und wenn sie erst mal eine bestimmte Masse haben, dann fängt die an, unter ihrem Eigengewicht langsam zusammenzufallen. Dem stehen halt Prozesse entgegen. Wenn Dinge so zusammenfallen, also wenn sie sehen, wie in der Badewanne das Wasser abläuft, durch das zentrale Abflussloch, dann fängt es an zu rotieren. Und das ist in diesen Molekülwolken ähnlich, wenn die anfangen zusammenzufallen, wird diese Rotation immer schneller, wie bei so einer prima Ballerina auf dem Eis, wenn sie ihre Arme anzieht. Und irgendwann ist die Rotation so schnell, dass diese Gravitativ-Anziehungskraft ausgleicht und dann würde nichts mehr passieren. Gleichzeitig heizt sich das Ganze auf, dadurch dass es, wenn sie ihren Fahrradreifen aufpumpen mit der Luftpumpe und sie komprimieren, die Luft wird sie warnen und heißer und heißer. Und so ist das da auch. Und auch das wirkt der weiteren Kontraktion entgegen. Das heißt, sie haben zwei Probleme bei der Sternentstehung. Aber mindestens, wahrscheinlich gibt es noch viele mehr. Einmal, wie kriege ich diesen Drehimpuls, diese Rotation, Drehimpuls genannte Energie weg? Und wie kriege ich die Wärme weg? Und die Wärme strahlt eben im Infrarotbereich. Kann sie abgestrahlt werden, dadurch führe ich die Wärme raus, diese Molkülwolke kühlt und kann sich weiter kontrahieren. Und diese Rotation kriege ich zum Teil durch Reibungseffekte, durch Fragmentation dieser Wolken, durch Turbulenz und so weiter. Und das macht es gerade im Infrarotbereich so wichtig, sich die Details dieser Sternentstehung anzuschauen. Das grobe Szenario ist, glaube ich, unstrittig, aber was sind die wesentlichen Details? Warum entstehen manchmal Einzelsterne? Warum entstehen manchmal Doppelsterne oder ganze Sternhaufen? Und dazu muss man sehr detailliert in diese Wolken reinschauen, in die Anfänge dieser Geschichten, aber auch die ganzen Prozesse begleiten. Und es gibt eine ganz prominente Linie Kohlmonoxid, CO, die bei 159 Mikrometer, glaube ich, sind es, eine sehr stark Wärmestrahlung abgibt. Das heißt, dieses Molekül wird durch Stöße, also Wärme ist ja eigentlich nur Bewegung von Molekülen, durch die Stöße in dieser Wolke heisst es sich quasi auf und strahlt dann diese Energie, die es durch einen Stoß bekommen hat, in Form von Infrarot-Strahlung ab. Das heißt, ein sehr effizienter Kühlmechanismus. Deswegen ist das eine sehr interessante Linie, die wir Astronomen gerne beobachten wollen. Und was sie dann zusätzlich machen, man macht eben nicht nur Bilder mit Kameras, sondern man untersucht auch durch das Spektrometer, durch die spektale Verteilung. Es gibt ja diese Rot- und Blauverschiebungen, die man hat. Das kennt man ja von den Martinshörnern, diese Veränderungen der Wellenlänge.
Also höherer Ton, wenn es auf einen zukommt, tieferer Ton, wenn es wegfährt.
Richtig, genau. Und das ist ja eine Information über die Geschwindigkeit, mit der dieses Gaselement, Staub, Moleküle, Wolken-Element auf mich zukommt oder von mir wegfliegt. Und wenn ich das sehr detailliert untersuchen kann, mit hoher Genauigkeit, kann ich dort Neuigkeiten von besser als einem Kilometer pro Sekunde Geschwindigkeiten, was sehr wenig ist im Weltall, da gibt es also schon ganz andere Geschwindigkeiten. Kriege ich sehr gute Informationen über die Dynamik dieser Wolke. Ich scanne die ganze Wolke durch und sehe unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeiten. Kann daraus über die Rotation der Wolke meine Schlüsse ziehen, über turbulente Bewegungen dort. Das heißt, ich bekomme nicht nur Informationen über die Dichte, die in dieser Wolke und über die elementare Zusammensetzung, sondern auch, wie sich die ganzen einzelnen Blöckchen dort bewegen. Das gibt mir sehr gut die ganze Dynamik.
Also die relative Geschwindigkeit innerhalb dieser Wolke, weil ja diese ganzen Galaxien im Verhältnis zu uns, allein schon durch die Ausdehnung des Universums, sich ja mit artenberobbener Geschwindigkeit bewegen und auch von uns weg bewegen.
Ja, mich interessiert nicht die Geschwindigkeit einer Molekülwolke, wo Sternentstehung beginnt als Ganzes, ob sie auf mich zu rast oder weg. Das ist mir egal, aber wie ist die Dynamik innerhalb der Wolke? Wie bewegt sich das innerhalb der Wolke? Rotiert es sehr stark, expandiert es, kontrahiert es? All das kann ich aus diesen Informationen bekommen.
Ein anderes, sehr bekanntes, klassisches Feld, teilweise haben wir es jetzt schon angesprochen, Infrarot-Beobachtung ist ja auch so der Urknall als Seuche. Also die Entdeckung der Hintergrundstrahlung durch Tabelteleskops seiner Zeit war es doch, ne?
Ja, die Hintergrundstrahlung hat man schon am Boden gemessen. Das war 1953, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Das waren zwei Techniker der Bell Laboratories in New York, die eine große Hornantenne eingereicht hatten für irgendwelche irischen Messzwecke und dann auch ein Störsignal irgendwoher kam und gar nicht wussten, was es war. Und dann haben sie gemerkt, es kommt aus dem Weltall. Das waren die Professoren Penzias und Wilson, die da für den Nobelpreis bekommen haben. Aber was sie dort eigentlich beobachtet haben, das mussten ihnen andere Astronomen erklären, weil sie waren halt nicht auf diesem Gebiet selber aktiv. Sie haben nur gemerkt, da ist diese Strahlung, sie haben die entdeckt. Und Nobelpreise bekommt man in der Regel für Entdeckungen und nicht für Erklärungen. So ist halt der Nobelpreis angelegt. Es ist sehr selten, dass irgendein theoretischer Astronom einen Nobelpreis bekommt oder ein theoretischer Physiker. Man muss irgendein Teilchen entdecken oder irgendein Phänomen entdecken. Dann bekommt man ihn am meisten auch erst nach manch, erst wenn sie tot sind oder nach vielen Jahren.
Das könnte ich ja auch noch mal einkriegen, wenn ich zufällig in irgendwas reinlaufe, um dafür erklärt zu können.
Ja, das ist also schon lange her. Das misst man auch mehr im Radiobereich. Dazu braucht man im Infrarot nicht unbedingt messen. Der Grund, warum man auch im Infrarotbereich sogenannte extragalaktische Astronomie, also Astronomie außerhalb unserer Milchstraße machen kann, bis eben an den Rand des Urknalls, liegt darin, wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben, durch diese Rotverschiebung. Wenn ich weit in die Ferne schaue, schaue ich auch weit zurück in die Zeit. Und das ganze explodiert das Weltall durch den Urknall. Und je weiter ich zurückschaue, umso höher sind auch die Geschwindigkeiten. Und durch diese hohen Geschwindigkeiten sind die Galaxien, die ersten Galaxien, die vor 13 Milliarden Jahren circa entstanden sind, so schnell, dass sie das optische, dass man das Licht gar nicht, was im optischen Abstrahlen hier auf der Erde, im Infrarot verschoben ist. Das heißt, wenn ich Infrarotmessungen mache, also wenn ich im optischen schaue, sehe ich sie gar nicht mehr, weil das Licht ist ins Infrarote verschoben.
Also die Wellen sind sozusagen durch das Wegfliegen der Galaxie, das so eine hohe Geschwindigkeit hat, nur so in die Länge gezogen, dass einfach die Frequenzen raus aus dem sichtbaren Bereich ins Infrarot sich verschieben.
Also eine typische Helium-Linie oder Stickstoff-Linie, die man hier auf der Erde, in unserer Galaxie, im sichtbaren sehen würde, sieht man nur noch im Infraroten, weil sie halt rot verschoben ist. Das heißt, die würde ich mit optischen Teleskopen gar nicht mehr sehen können.
Also die Infrarot-Astronomie ist eine ganz wesentliche Komponente der Grundlagenforschung.
Das ist, wie schon mehrfach gesagt, ich kriege eben wesentliche Informationen über das Weltall, indem ich das gesamte Wellenlängenspektrum betrachte. Das geht vom Radiobereich, übers optische Infrarot, Röntgen, Gamma-Bereich bis zu der Teilchenstrahlung, die aus dem Weltall kommt. Und da ist das Infrarotspektrum ein sehr wesentliches, weil es viele interessante Informationen enthält, gerade im molekularen Bereich. Also man hat im Weltall die kuriosesten Moleküle entdeckt, Essigsäure oder Ameisensäure und ganz exotische Sachen, wo man dann auf der Erde, also man beobachtet Spektren, die man auf der Erde noch gar nicht gesehen hat. Man weiß also nicht immer, was ich da eigentlich beobachtet habe. Man muss dann rechnen, was könnte es sein? Und dann muss man ins Labor gehen, ein Chemielabor, und genau dieses Element oder dieses Molekül zusammenbasteln, und schauen, strahlt das genauso mit dieser Charakteristik ab. Also oft ist es so, dass man erst im Labor nachher verifizieren kann, was man genau für eine Linie beobachtet hat.
Weil das sich ja einfach hier so auf der Welt nicht befindet, oder zumindest als solches noch nicht entdeckt oder untersucht wurde.
Oder befindet weit schon. Dazu muss man sagen, gerade bei Molekülen, diese Linien entstehen dadurch, dass diese Moleküle, die Atome im Molekül gegeneinander schwingen oder das ganze Molekül rotiert. Und da gibt es sehr viele Anregungsstufen. Also wenn es ein bisschen schneller rotiert, dann kann es von einer Rotation an einem schnellen Rotationszustand dann langsam runterfallen, dabei strahlt es eine bestimmte Linie ab. Und nun gibt es sehr hoch angeregte Moleküle, die auf der Erde so gar nicht existieren, weil hier die Dichte viel zu groß ist. Im Weltall ist die Dichte trotz, also immer wenn die Astronomen von dichten Molekülwolken sprechen, ist das immer noch nach unseren Vorstellungen unendlich dünn. Und da kann so ein Molekül auch länger leben, bevor es in den Zustand wieder runterfällt und dann diese charakteristische Strahlung abgibt. Und das sagt sehr viel über die Temperatur in so einer Wolke aus. Temperatur, Dichte lassen sich über diese Parameter sehr gut festlegen. Also man hat quasi so ein Fernwärmemessgerät.
Astronomische Fernwärme.
Ja, nicht Fernwärme, aber Messgerät, Thermometer.
Das ist ja Fernwärme, man spürt sie nicht unbedingt auf der Haut, aber sie kommt ja an, sonst könnte man sie nicht beobachten.
Ja, also die Wärme, die von der Sonne kommt, spürt man auf der Haut. Es hat sich ja gezeigt, oder wie üblich, also die Entwicklung, die in der Grundlagenphysik, in der Astronomie gemacht wird, hat ja auch sehr schnell oft auch irrische Anwendungen. Also im optischen Sinn waren das früher die Kameras, heute sind es die CCD-Kameras. Die sind ja nicht für den irrischen Bedarf entwickelt worden, sondern diese CCD-Chips sind eine Entwicklung aus der Astronomie. Weil die Astronomen haben halt immer wahnsinnige Anforderungen an die Größe, an die Auflösung, an die Stabilität. Und das wird dann später kommerziell verwendet. Und im Infraroten war es ähnlich. Auch da hatten die Astronomen sehr starkes Interesse. Hier war es vielleicht sogar so, dass da das Militär noch der stärkere Interesse hatte und die Astronomen vielleicht von der militärischen Forschung profitiert haben. In gewissen Bereichen jedenfalls, im nahen Infrarotbereich. Und das sind halt diese Wärmebildkameras, die es heutzutage gibt. Nachtsichtgeräte aus diesem Bereich und Wärmebildkameras, mit denen man den Energiehaushalt von Häusern messen kann, wo sind die Schwachstellen. Also das ist, genau so macht man es im Weltall. Man schaut mit ähnlichen Kameras, die natürlich sehr viel genauer sind und besser abgeglichen und besser kalibriert sind, auf eine Molekülwolke und sieht, wo strahlt sie ab und wo nicht. Wo hat sie ihre Löcher? Da bin ich die Information, die ich auch beim Haus gewinne. Also das kann man schon vergleichen.
Gibt es abgesehen von dem grundsätzlichen Ziel des Grundlagen-Erforschens und des Verstehens der Zusammenhänge, gibt es jetzt auch ganz spezifische Kernprobleme, die man gerade versucht durch Infrarot-Astronomie besser zu verstehen? Oder ist es eigentlich eher so eine Gesamtlage, aus der man alle möglichen Erkenntnisse sieht, von denen man heute noch gar nicht weiß, was es sein könnte?
Also es ist einmal ein generelles Tool, aber wenn Sie einen Astronom nach dem anderen fragen, käme jeder mit seinem Spezialgebiet natürlich an.
Also jeder Charter mit einem anderen Huf.
Ja, also einmal ist es natürlich in der Tat das, was sich in diesen dunklen Molekülwolken abspielt, tief drinnen, wo eben der Prozess der Sternwertung beginnt, des Zusammenklumpens auch von übrig gebliebenen Teilchen, aus denen dann Planeten entstehen. Da bilden sich so Scheiben. Wie gesagt, wenn sich so etwas kontrahiert, wird eben viel in Drehimpuls umgesetzt und das Ganze rotiert. Das sieht man auch in unserem Planeten-System. Wir rotieren in einer flachen Scheibe. Man sieht das an Galaxien, die in diesen Scheiben spiralen.
Die ganze D-Straße ist im Prinzip eine Scheibe.
Genau, das ist das Prinzip.
Die Welt ist eine Scheibe, nicht wahr?
Ja. Und selbst im Endprozess, wenn kurz bevor Sterne explodieren und sie von Nachbarsternen gasaufsaugen, sammelt sich das in einer sogenannten Aggression-Scheibe um diesen kompakten Stern herum. Weißen Zwerg, Neutronenstern. Und wird dort in unglaublich schnelle Rotationen versetzt. Und Reibung strahlt dann im Röntgen-Gammerbereich ab. Das sind schon extreme Prozesse, auch am Ende des Sternlebens. Findet das in der Scheibe statt. Der Stern ist kugelrund. Und wenn er explodiert, ist es dann eher so ein symmetrisches Ereignis. Aber auch da gibt es, ja, Jets. Und die da rausschießen.
Die Idee jetzt, gibt es zu dem Bereich noch was?
Ich hatte, nach den Schwerpunkten, das ist einmal die Sternentstehung, dann eben, wie sind Galaxien entstanden? Dazu nutzt man eben, wenn man sehr tief ins Weltrand reinschaut, durch diese Rotverschiebung, wo eben Großteil der Strahlungsenergie jetzt im Infraroten zu uns kommt. Das hatten wir schon erwähnt. Ja, es gibt diese Kometen, Asteroiden, oder auch diese sehr kleinen Staubteilchen, die im Weltall verteilt sind. Auf deren Oberflächen spielen sich chemische Prozesse ab. Also kleine Staubteilchen dienen als Katalysator zum Beispiel, wo dann verschiedene Moleküle sich anlagern und chemische Reaktionen eingehen. Und es gibt Physiker, Astronomen, die davon ausgehen, dass sich dort auch präbiotisches Material, also Vorstufen von einfachsten Aminosäuren, Bausteinen des Lebens entwickeln. Und es gibt die Theorie, dass zum Beispiel das Leben nicht auf der Erde hier entstanden ist, sondern dass die Ursprungsformen des Lebens, die einfachsten Bausteine, bis zu Bakterien usw., von außen auf die Erde runtergerechnet sind, auf die frühe Erde, und sich dann weiterentwickelt haben. Und das ist auch etwas, wo die Astronomen in diese Molekülwolken reinschauen und sie dort die merkwürdigsten Moleküle finden. Und die Frage ist, entsteht dort weit draußen im Weltrahmen auf diesen kleinen Staubkörnchen sowas wie Aminosäuren? Und die würden sich eben auch durch charakteristische Spektren nachweisen lassen.
Also die Infrarot-Astronomie ist nicht nur, aber auch so eine Art dreidimensionales Fernrohr in Wolkengebilde, in denen die einfach hochaktiv sind, in denen Sterne entstehen, die gerade aus zerstörten Sternen sich gebildet haben, die einfach eine Vielzahl an Erkenntnissen bieten, um Sternentstehungen, Galaxieentstehungen, Universumsentstehungen etc. in Sicht zu überprüfen oder mit weiteren Theorien zu befüttern. ZB eben auch diese Frage von Lebensentstehungen im Weltall neu aufzuwerfen. Wollen wir jetzt mal wieder langsam ein bisschen zurück zu dem SOFIA Projekt und warum man sich denn jetzt konkret für dieses Modell entwickelt hat. Ich weiß nicht, seit wann gibt es jetzt so vergleichbare Infrarot-Teleskope überhaupt?
Also vergleichbar auch im Weltall zu Ende der 60er, Anfang der 70er Jahre. Man hat am Anfang eben war man, was ja ein völlig Neues, man war sich nicht so sicher, kann ich überhaupt Infrarot-Schralungen empfangen. Man hat also mit kleinen Flugzeugen z.B. begonnen, Learjet, so wo man vielleicht ein 20-30 cm Teleskop, also Durchmesserspiegels, an einen Kabinenfenster rausschauen lässt und hat dann mal getestet, was kann ich messen. Dann hat sich rausgeholt, ja es funktioniert. Und dann hat die NASA 1973, wenn ich mich erinnere, erstmals ein ordentliches Flugzeug-Observatorium eingesetzt. Das war das Koiper Airborne Observatory, KAO abgekürzt. Das war eine ehemalige Militärmaschine, ein Truppentransporter. Der wurde so umgebaut, umgerüstet, dass er ein Teleskop im vorderen Teil, oberhalb vor dem Flügel hatte, was durch eine zu öffnende Tür eben frei ins Weltall rausschauen konnte. Dieses Teleskop hatte einen Hauptspiegel, der die Photonen sammelt, von 90 cm Durchmesser. Und dieses KAO ist 20 Jahre, 22 Jahre geflogen und hat quasi diese Infrarot-Astronomie vom Flugzeug aus revolutioniert. Das war das erste, was auch ständig regelmäßig fliegen konnte. Und es sind dort über die 20 Jahre etwa 8 bis 10 bis 12 verschiedene Instrumente eingesetzt worden, von Kameras bis Spektrometern, Polarimetern etc., ganze Bandbreite.
Also auch nicht unbedingt beschränkt jetzt auf Infrarot?
Doch, auf Infrarot.
Aber gäbe es nicht auch einen Einsatz für andere Spektralbereiche in so einem Flugzeug?
Also das Optische kann ich von Boden aus direkt messen. Oder man geht auf hohe Berge, um eben da die Verzerrung auch rauszuhaben. Zum Teil den Wasserdampf rauszuhaben, die Wolken wegzuhaben.
Das würde dann sozusagen reichen. Da bringt dann ein Flugzeug nicht genug Extra, um den Aufwand nicht zurechtfertigen?
Richtig, da bringt es nicht extra. Wenn ich im Röntgenbereich im Flugzeug schaue, sind auch 10, 12, 14 Kilometer Höhe noch nicht genug. Da muss ich bis auf Ballonhöhe gehen, von 38, 40 Kilometern Höhe. Das ist die maximale Höhe, diese Ballons zu gehen.
Und da fliegt dann eigentlich kein Flugzeug mehr?
Das macht man dann zum Teil mit Ballons, wo dann Instrumente dranhängen, die Röntgen-Gamma-Strahlung gemessen haben und auch diese Partikel-Teilchen-Strahlung, die aus dem Weltall kommt. Und Flugzeughöhe ist halt gerade dazwischen. Also das ist eigentlich sinnvoll nutzbar. Es ist ideal, um es im Infrarot-Bereich zu nutzen. Alles andere muss ich entweder ins Weltall gehen oder kann ich es vom Boden aus besser machen.
Aber woran haben sich denn diese unterschiedlichen Instrumente, die da eingesetzt wurden, unterschieden? Haben die unterschiedliche Prinzipien? Hat man da sozusagen getestet, was am besten funktioniert? Oder haben die auch alle ganz andere Arten und Weisen gehabt zu messen?
Das ist natürlich auch ein Aspekt, den ich noch gar nicht erwähnt hatte, den Sie ansprechen, dass man auf diesen Flugzeug-Observatorien ein Instrument auch testen kann, ein einfaches Instrument, und schauen, ob das Prinzip funktioniert, und mess ich was. Wenn es das nicht tut, habe ich wenig Geld verplempert. Wenn ich das im Weltall mache, gebe ich eine Milliarde aus und habe nachher kein Ergebnis. Viele der Instrumente, die heutzutage auf Infrarot-Satelliten eingesetzt werden, sind in diesem KAO auch quasi vorgetestet worden. Und deren Prinzip ist dort bestätigt worden, dass man sagt, prima, das funktioniert ja. Wenn ich das jetzt auf einen Satelliten im Weltall bringe, dann funktioniert es noch besser. Aber es funktioniert überhaupt. Und das ist auch eine der Möglichkeiten mit SOFIA, dass man die neuste Technologie, die man dort einsetzt, mit SOFIA auch verifiziert. Ich mache tolle Wissenschaft damit. Gleichzeitig zeige ich, daraus könnte ich auch ein Weltall-Experiment bauen, wenn ich denn eine Fluggelegenheit ins Weltall bekomme. Das Simpelste ist, man hat eine Kamera und kriegt ein Bild wie beim Hubble. Das ist immer sehr eindrucksvoll und auch einleuchtend, was man sieht. Und dann sind diese bunten Farben, die man am Infrarot-Bild sieht, natürlich künstlich und sollen also nur die unterschiedlichen Wellenlängenbereiche darstellen. Das heißt, das menschliche Auge ist ja im Infrarot, man sieht nichts, und das ist nur eine Hilfe. Das sind falsch oder Fehlfarben, wie es so schön heißt, aber man macht damit die Unterschiede sehr gut sichtbar. Das sind Kameras. Das andere, was ich vorhin erwähnt hatte, dass man ja sehr gerne Spektren aufnehmen möchte, die mir sehr viel mehr über Dichte, Temperatur, Geschwindigkeit, bestimmter Elemente aussagen. Dazu habe ich halt Spektrometer, die mir nur eine Linie abbilden. Wenn ich das dann über eine ganze Molekülwolke machen muss, dann muss ich die abrastern, abscannen. Ich mache eine Aufnahme dieser Position, gehe ein paar Bogenminuten weiter nach rechts und fahre das ganze Bibel durch und mache meine Aufnahmen, bis ich so eine Karte zusammengerastert habe.
Wie so ein Flachbett-Scanner?
Ja, wie so ein Scanner darüber gehen. Da gibt es die unterschiedlichsten Instrumente. Ich spreche immer von Infrarot-Astronomie. Auch das ist kein homogener Bereich, sondern da gibt es das Nah-Infrarot, das Mittel-Infrarot, das Fern-Infrarot und dann noch den Submillimeterbereich. Der Bereich, der mit SOFIA abgedeckt wird, geht etwa von einem Mikrometer bis zu einem Millimeter. Das ist der Schwerpunkt zwischen 5 und 500 Mikrometern. Wenn ich zum Beispiel für 5 Mikrometer einen Detektor habe, der funktioniert nicht mehr bei 25 oder bei 200. Das heißt, ich muss dort unterschiedliche Technologien einsetzen. Wenn ich eine CCD-Kamera habe, der Chip nimmt mir vom blauen bis zum roten Licht alles auf. Im Infrarot-Bereich sind die Detektoren nur für eine eng begrenzte Wellenlänge empfindlich. Das heißt, ich muss unterschiedliche Detektoren, unterschiedliche Technologien entwickeln, um die unterschiedlichen Spektralbereiche abdecken zu können. Das erfordert dann auch unterschiedliche Konzepte im Instrument, unterschiedliche Detektionsmechanismen.
Das ist ja auch bestimmt knifflig. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt unterschiedliche Instrumente hat, um die unterschiedlichen Bereiche zu analysieren, müssen die dann nicht auch noch so ein bisschen aufeinander abgestimmt werden, um so ein homogenes Bild überhaupt zu liefern. Das schaut ja dann jeder so ein bisschen anders, auf eine andere Art und Weise, mit anderen Verfälschungen.
Wenn ein neues Instrument kommt und misst am Himmel und sagt, ja, diese Moleküle wurde gestarrt doch doppelt so stark wie vorher angenommen. Dann kann es sein, dass entweder der Vorgänger sein Instrument nicht ordentlich hatte oder der Nachfolger. Das heißt, man muss dann diese Instrumente an Quellen am Himmel, die genau bekannt sind, eichen. Das macht man im Infrarot-Bereich oder zum Beispiel an den Planeten. Da weiß man relativ genau, mit welcher Intensität sie absteigen, zum Beispiel Jupiter oder Saturn. Das heißt, oft beginnt so eine Beobachtungssequenz ganz am Anfang der 8-Stunden-Messzeit, dass ich mal eine Viertelstunde auf Saturn schaue und sehe, was das Signal ist, und dann habe ich einen Kalibrationspunkt. Dann habe ich mein Instrument sozusagen geeicht, dann habe ich meinen Nullpunkt, und dann wird das aufeinander abgestimmt.
Ah, verstehe. Jetzt waren wir ja bei diesem KAO, bei diesem Koiper, das war eine reine NASA-Entwicklung.
Ja, wie gesagt, das Flugzeug wurde von NASA inhouse am NASA Ames Research Center in Mountain View umgebaut mit Hilfe von Firmen. Das wurde also nicht in einem Großauftrag, zum Beispiel bei Boeing oder Lock-It, sondern inhouse gemacht. Und auch das Teleskop wurde weitgehend von NASA entwickelt. Also es war ein reines NASA-Projekt ohne internationale Beteiligung. Und wie sind die Deutschen da reingekommen? Warum haben wir jetzt mit SOFIA ein gemeinsames Projekt mit NASA? Das hat zum einen mit zu tun, dass die Instrumententwicklung für die Detektoren, die Instrumente, die auf KAO SOFIA eingesetzt wurden, dass da die deutschen Institute, Forschungsinstitute, astronomische Institute zum Teil führend auf ihrem Gebiet waren in Vorbereitung auf Weltraumobservatoren oder grundsätzlich solche Instrumente in der Entwicklung hatten. Und dann von NASA eingeladen wurden, auf dem KAO mitzufliegen. Also es gab kein Agreement zwischen DLR und NASA, sondern das DLR war auch nicht beteiligt, sondern einfach aufgrund der technologischen Kompetenz und der astronomischen Kompetenz diverser Institute, Forschungsinstitute hier in Deutschland, sind sie von NASA eingeladen worden. Weil NASA hat gesagt, okay, das Thema ist so interessant, da gibt es nur zwei Instrumente hier in Deutschland, die sind einzigartig, wir laden die Deutschen ein, das zu nutzen, ohne dass eine Kompensation gebracht werden musste. Bei dem einen oder anderen Instrument war es dann so, dass amerikanische Wissenschaftler mitkooperiert haben und die Daten mitnutzen konnten, aber das war die Basis. Und der zweite Grund, warum NASA und dadurch sind die Verbindungen zustande gekommen und dann haben die deutschen Wissenschaftler das DLR bedrängt, als NASA darüber nachdachte, ein Folge-Observatorium zu bauen. Sie kennen die Wissenschaftler, man baut ihnen ein wunderschönes Observatorium und kaum ist es in Betrieb, sagen sie, wir hätten lieber ein noch größeres. Und das ist halt der Wissensdrang, der dahintersteckt, immer etwas Größeres, Neues, noch Besseres zu haben, weil man, das haben wir jetzt gemessen, aber da sind neue Fragen aufgetaucht, dazu brauchen wir ein größeres Teleskop.
Aber dieses KAO, das folgt doch im Prinzip derselben, also SOFIA folgt derselben Idee wie das KAO. Also im Prinzip kann man sagen, dass SOFIA die Version 2.0 ist von diesem KAO.
Weitgehend kann man so sagen.
Aber was war denn jetzt falsch an dem ersten Flugzeug, das jetzt wirklich ein neues erforderlich war?
Also es war nichts falsch, es war sehr erfolgreich. Beispiele zu nennen, der Satellit Uranus hat, wie auch der Saturn, so ein Ringsystem. Das hat man zum Beispiel mit dem KAO erstmals entdeckt. Also das ist eine der, vielleicht auch noch eine Bemerkung am Rande, eine der Vorteile eines flugzeuggetragenen Observatoriums, wenn sie solche Bedeckungen machen wollen. Man weiß das von der Sonnenfinsternis, das ist ein schmaler Streifen, der hier auf der Erde langläuft, meistens in der Arktis oder überm Pazifik. Also hier in Deutschland ist es ganz selten, alle 100 Jahre hat man mal eine Sonnenfinsternis. Mit dem Flugzeug kann ich einfach dahin fliegen, wo es gerade ist. Während die bodengebundenen Observatorien, auch im Optischen, immer da stehen, wo gerade keine Sonnenfinsternis ist. Die kann ich ja nicht bewegen.
Ja, Satelliten auch.
Und Satelliten ist auch schwierig, ja, richtig. Und nun wird man mit SOFIA nicht Sonnenfinsternisse beobachten, aber es gibt eben z.B. von weit entfernten Planeten wie Pluto, der jetzt ja offiziell ein Kleinplanet ist, der hat da im Moment noch relativ nah an der Sonne. Er hat eine starke elliptische Bahn um die Sonne, bewegt sich gerade von der Sonne fort, geht man davon aus, dass er noch eine kleine Restatmosphäre hat. Wenn er weit genug weg ist, dann friert die aus und kondensiert und regnet runter. Und wenn man jetzt einen Hintergrundstern hat, wo der Pluto an diesem Hintergrundstern wobei fliegt, dann wird der Hintergrundstern die Atmosphäre durchleuchten. Und aus der Abschwächung des Lichts und aus der Absorption kann ich dann Erkenntnisse über die Atmosphäre des Pluto gewinnen.
Aber da muss man an der richtigen Stelle sein.
Da muss man exakt an der richtigen Stelle sein. Der Pfad unten auf der Erde, auf dem sich das abbildet, ist vielleicht 10 Kilometer breit und auch nur 500 Kilometer lang. Das heißt, ich muss genau am richtigen Zeitpunkt an der richtigen Stelle sein. Das ist einmal schon eine logistische Herausforderung. Das genau festzustellen, zu messen, das sind ja sehr feine... Ich muss die Position beider Himmelskörper und der Erde schon sehr genau kennen und ständig, je näher es kommt, aktualisieren. Und ich muss mit dem Flugzeug genau da sein. Das hat man mit dem KAO mehrfach gemacht.
Wie fliegt denn dann das Flugzeug automatisiert? Oder kann dann ein Pilot das auch so umsetzen, das exakt genauso zu treffen?
Der Pilot bekommt die Flugdaten und fliegt dann selber, eventuell mit Autopilot, aber es ist nicht automatisiert. Das war weder beim KAO noch im Moment bei SOFIA so.
Aber es ist dann schon eine extrem vorausberechnete Flugbahn, weil man kann ja nicht mal eben ein bisschen lang oder ein bisschen langsamer und noch ein bisschen weiter links. Da muss er eigentlich schon mal so in den richtigen Weg sein und dann bestenfalls noch Justierungen vornehmen.
Ja, und dann hat man eine Viertelstunde Zeit und dann klappt das in der Viertelstunde oder nicht. Und das war's dann.
Und die nächste Gelegenheit ist dann erst wieder...
Ja, bei einer Sonnenfinanz wäre es alle paar Jahre, aber wenn man...
So eine Pluto-Konstellation.
Auch Pluto ist vielleicht auch einmal im Jahr oder zweimal. Im Moment wird darüber nachgedacht oder ist in der Planung, dass man jetzt in diesem Sommer, Mitte Juni, zwei Gelegenheiten hat, über dem Pazifik genau das mit Pluto zu machen. Und das plant man im Moment so zu tun. Das wäre, ich glaube, am 23., 29. Juni gibt es die Gelegenheit. Und da wird man das versuchen, wenn jetzt nichts dazwischenkommt.
Welcher Stern ist das dann?
Das kann ich im Moment nicht sagen.
Aber ich meine...
Der Stern ist eigentlich weniger von Bedeutung. Ich brauche eigentlich nur eine Lichtquelle als Hintergrund. Aber es gibt andere Körper im System.
Eine Sterne gibt es ja genug, aber nicht unbedingt genug, die jetzt genug Energie haben, um dann auch für diese Messung vornehmen zu können.
Also helle Sterne gibt es halt. Je heller die Sterne sind, umso weniger gibt es. Oder sind halt weiter weg. Und es gibt aber gerade außerhalb auch der Pluto-Bahn im Kuiper-Beld. Und da gibt es also noch Pluto-ähnliche Planeten, die man jetzt peu à peu entdeckt. Und da fragt man sich auch, haben die noch eine Atmosphäre? Oder wenn... Ich kriege nicht nur Informationen über die Atmosphäre, auch die Zeitdauer, die das Licht verschwindet, sagt mir ja was über die Größe dieses Objekts aus. Ich habe also eine mechanische Messung, die ich vergleichen kann mit der Strahlung, Restwärmestrahlung, die dieser ferne Kleinplanet mir abgibt. Und wenn ich diese Strahlungsintensität habe, die auf der Erde ankommt, und ich habe die Größe, dann kann ich etwas über die Temperatur dieses Objekts aussagen. Ansonsten, wenn ich die doppelte Strahlungsmenge bekäme, kann das Objekt heißer sein. Wenn ich mehr Energie bekomme, kann es aber auch größer sein. Das ist dann korreliert, wenn ich eine mechanische Messung vornehmen kann. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum man diese Okkultations-, Beobachtungs-, Bedeckungs-Messungen machen möchte.
Das kann ich.
Das mache ich im Optischen. Dazu brauche ich also nicht unbedingt das Infrarote. Aber ich nehme das Flugzeug dazu, weil ich da weltweit flexibel bin. Ich kann auf jedem Punkt der Erde mit SOFIA hinfliegen. Ich kann jetzt nicht 14 Stunden am Stück fliegen und messen, aber ich kann ja zwei Tage vorher zur Osterinsel fliegen.
Ist denn das dann eigentlich eine Aufgabe des Kern-SOFIA-Teams selber? Oder ist das dann nicht schon viel mehr eine permanente Zusammenarbeit mit unabhängigen oder auch in selben Institutionen arbeitenden Wissenschaftlergruppen, die dann sagen, hier, wir hätten da eine Chance und könnt ihr den nicht vielleicht... Oder hat man da einfach jetzt innerhalb von SOFIA sich schon rausgeguckt, was man alles machen könnte, und das macht man dann einfach?
Es gibt ein breites Band von Nutzern, potenziellen Nutzern bei SOFIA. Es gibt welche, die möchten halt ihre Bestimm-Molekül-Spektrallinien messen. Die möchten wissen, wie läuft die Chemie da ab? Und dann gibt es eben Astronomen, die sich auf dieser Bedeckung spezialisiert haben und die eben auch versuchen, wenn denn alle zwei Jahre mal so eine Bedeckung mit einem bodengebundenen Teleskop möglich ist, weil es zufällig an der richtigen Stelle steht, das auch schon gemacht haben, da Erfahrung haben. Da gehört viel Erfahrung zu. Das heißt, wie überall in der Wissenschaft, haben sich die Wissenschaftler und auch die Astronomen spezialisiert auf ein ganz bestimmtes Gebiet. Sie kooperieren natürlich mit ihren Kollegen, um Informationen zusammenzubringen, weil nur die eine Information in der Regel selten einen großen Fortschritt bringt. Aber derjenige, der genau dieses Instrument betreibt, ist ein Spezialist auf diesem Instrument, weil die so hochgradig an der technologischen Grenze sind, dass man dieses Spezialwissen braucht. Kein Astronom heute kann mehr in der Detektertechnologie das ganze Spektrum abdecken. Die Astronomen haben sicherlich alle einen großen Überblick, was insgesamt passiert, aber wenn es um ganz konkrete Einzelfragen, was ist das Signal zu Rauschverhältnis meines Detektors, dann muss er da Spezialist auf diesem technologischen Gebiet eines bestimmten Detektors sein. Und so ist das auch, was die Bedeckung angeht, gibt es den Spezialisten, die sich für sowas stark machen. Und die bringen natürlich ihre Vorschläge ein und sagen, das sind die Möglichkeiten und müssen halt diese Vorschläge einreichen. Und dann werden sie bewertet wie alle anderen Vorschläge auch. Die Messzeit auf SOFIA und auf dem KAO ist begrenzt. Es gibt also deutlich mehr Wünsche, Beobachtungen zu machen, als Messzeit zur Verfügung steht. Und das Ganze läuft in einem Auswahlverfahren, wo unabhängige Experten sich die Vorschläge anschauen einmal im Jahr und dann ein Ranking machen und sagen, das sind die besten Proposal, die sollen zum Zuge kommen. Dann muss es dann mit der Betriebsmannschaft noch, muss dann schauen, wie ich diese Proposal innerhalb eines Jahres in eine bestimmte Sequenz, wie mache ich meinen Stundenplan, dass das auch klappt. Wenn ich nur Vorschläge habe, die zum Beispiel das Milchstraßenzentrum beobachten wollen, dann kann ich das nicht das ganze Jahr über machen, von der Nordthermisphäre aus, weil zum großen Teil dann das galaktische Zentrum gar nicht sichtbar ist. Dann muss ich dann halt drei Monate mein Flugzeug, sagen wir, nach Neuseeland verlegen und von der Südhalbkugel aus messen. Das hat man mit dem KAO dann regelmäßig gemacht, dass man für mehrere Monate auf der Südhalbkugel war, weil es da halt auch interessante Objekte gibt, die man von der Nordhalbkugel gar nicht sehen kann. Darum gibt es eben sowohl auf der Nord- als auf der Südhalbkugel große Bodenobservatoren, damit man beide Hemisphären abdenken kann. Und ja, also gerade was diese Bedeckung angeht, ist es natürlich eine sehr difficile Geschichte. Da muss dann auch die Piloten-Crew genau mitstimmen. Also da muss die Kommunikation sehr gut sein, dass die exakt genau den Pfad fliegen, der auch vorhergesagt ist. Das heißt, ich muss also die Position des Flugzeugs auch sehr genau kennen zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ja, und das hat man mit dem KAO gezeigt, dass das geht. Und ja, warum waren die Wissenschaftler mit dem KAO nicht zufrieden? Das würde ich so gar nicht sagen. Sie waren sehr zufrieden. Es war sehr erfolgreich. Gerade weil es in den ersten Jahren diese, ich sag mal, Konkurrenz mit Infrarot-Observatoren so noch nicht gab. Das kam dann Ende der 70er-Jahre. Anfang der 80er-Jahre hatten die Amerikaner, die NASA, einen Infrarot-Satelliten zusammen mit den Niederländern und den Briten. Dann hatte die ESA das ISO, das Infrarot Space Observatory. Das vorletzte in der Reihe war das amerikanische Spitzer-Observatorium, das auch einen 90 cm Spiegel hatte. Das, was jetzt gerade fliegt, das Herrscherl, mit seinen 3,50 m, der größte Spiegel im Weltall, kommt von der ESA, nicht von der NASA, im Moment. Das ist, wie ich am Anfang erwähnte, der, der wahrscheinlich ein Jahr seinen Kühlvorrat verbraucht hat und damit nicht mehr einsetzbar sein wird.
Sehr kurze Laufzeit, aber halt extrem weit draußen.
Und kann, weil das ganze Gerät sehr kalt ist, sehr tief ins Weltall schauen. Während die flugzeuggetragenen Observatoren eben, weil sie immer noch, in der Stratosphäre ist es minus 40, minus 50 Grad kalt, aber das sind nicht die minus 270, die man im Weltall hat.
Ja, und gleich zum Weltall sind das tropische Bedingungen.
Das Teleskop strahlt also selber wie wild und ich muss ja so schauen, dass meine Dektatoren das nicht mitbekommen. Die Dektatoren selber im Flugzeug, die sind auf minus 270 Grad gekühlt, um überhaupt zu funktionieren. Also ich habe in der Kabine da meine Instrumente mit diesen Kühlmitteln. Ja, also die Astronomen waren eigentlich sehr zufrieden mit dem KAO, aber es geht ja immer noch etwas besser. Das war das erste größere Flugzeuggetragenen Observatorium und man hat eben sehr viel gelernt dabei. Und dann kam die Frage, was können wir denn noch besser machen? Zunächst mal ein größeres Teleskop, heißt größerer Spiegel, heißt größere Sammelfläche. Wenn ich einen doppelt so großen Spiegel habe, bekomme ich viermal so viele Photonen rein. Mein Rauschverhältnis geht nochmal ein Faktor 2 runter. Also mit einem doppelt so großen Spiegel kann ich im Prinzip in einem Achtel der Zeit das Gleiche messen. Und mit einem größeren Spiegel habe ich auch eine höhere Auflösung. Das heißt, ich kann Dinge, die eng beieinander liegen, besser trennen. Je größer der Spiegel ist, umso feinere Details kann ich räumlich beobachten. Das ist der Grund, ein größeres Teleskop zu haben.
Wie groß ist der Spiegel im SOFIA?
Der Spiegel im SOFIA ist jetzt 2,70 Meter, von dem 2,60 Meter optisch nutzbar sind. Das hat Gründe aus der speziellen Beobachtungstechnik. Und das ist also gut das Dreifache an Durchmesser des KAO. Und damit habe ich die zehnfache Sammelfläche. Und das ist natürlich ein erheblicher Fortschritt. Und das erkaufe ich mir, dass ich ein größeres Flugzeug brauche.
Das hätte jetzt sozusagen in das alte Flugzeug gar nicht reingepasst.
Nein, das hätte vom Volumen nicht reingepasst. Und natürlich auch vom Gewicht. Wenn ich meinen Spiegel größer mache, wird er schwerer und schwerer. Das ganze Zusatzgerüst, um ihn zu tragen, wird schwerer, alles wird schwerer. Das geht dann mit der dritten Potenz im schlimmsten Fall. Also wenn ich einen doppelt so großen Spiegel habe, habe ich ein achtfach größeres Gewicht. Das geht auch in einem SOFIA, in einem Jumbo-Jet nicht mehr rein. Das ist dann die Herausforderung an die Ingenieure, mit einem doppelt so großen Spiegel nicht das achtfache Gewicht zu bekommen, sondern vielleicht nur das doppelte Gewicht mit Leichtbau. Das war eine der großen Herausforderungen an die deutschen Ingenieure, die dieses Teleskop gebaut haben.
Was wiegt denn die gesamte Installation?
Das gesamte Teleskop wiegt 17 Tonnen plus 3 Tonnen an Zusatzequipment wie Elektronikrex, Ölversorgung, Kühlmechanismen etc., die im Flugzeug verteilt sind. Aber 17 Tonnen sind an diesem sogenannten Druckschott-Balkett im Flugzeug befestigt. Davon sind etwa 7 bis 8 Tonnen beweglich. Der Rest ist eine trage Struktur, die das gesamte am Flugzeug festhält.
17 Tonnen.
Das waren die Spezifikationen, die wir 1995 bekommen haben. Die deutschen Ingenieure haben ein Teleskop entwickelt und gebaut, das exakt diese 17 Tonnen eingehalten hat. Das war eine der Meisterleistungen, dass man dieses Gewicht eingehalten hat. Das ist oft eine große Herausforderung.
Also es sind sowieso 170-200 Passagiere. Für SOFIA wurde dann aber gleich eine Boeing 747 genommen. Die kann ja auch mehr tragen.
Man hat das größte Flugzeug genommen, was möglich ist, was es damals gab. Die ursprüngliche Idee war, das Teleskop vorne einzubauen, vor dem Flügel, wo dieser Puckel ist für die erste Klasse. Da haben wir viel Platz. Die ersten Ideen gingen auch hin. Man kann da ungefähr ein Teleskop reinbauen, das einen Spiegeldurchmesser von 3,50 m hat. Das würde auch rein theoretisch gehen.
Also man wollte eigentlich von vornherein so groß, wie nur irgendwie geht?
So groß wie geht. Und dann nimmt man das größte Flugzeug und schaut, was kriege ich da rein. Nun können sie da sicherlich einen 3,50 m Durchmesserspiegel reinbauen, aber der hat dann keine Halterung, kein gar nichts. Also wenn sie einen Spiegel bauen, dann muss er ja gefasst werden, man darf nicht wackeln. Sie brauchen Struktur drumrum und das wächst und wächst. Und das eigentliche Teleskop hat jetzt einen Durchmesser von 3,5 m, während der Spiegel nur noch 2,50 m hat. Das ist das, was machbar war. Also mit viel Gewalt hätte man 2,80 m vielleicht reinbekommen, aber das heißt auch, sie haben keinen Spielraum mehr. Wenn irgendwo jetzt noch eine Isolierung dran muss, dann geht das nicht mehr. Also man sollte nicht am Anfang alles so voll ausreizen, dann rennt man am Ende der Entwicklung in die Probleme rein. Man braucht dann ein bisschen Reserve. Und es war eine gute Entscheidung 1995 zu sagen, wir begrenzen uns auf 2,70 m physikalischer Durchmesser. Und das kriegen wir dann auch ein.
Aber es ist ja gar nicht vorne eingebaut worden.
Die Idee war, wenn man es vorne einbaut, wo dieser große Puckel ist, dann brauche ich nicht durch den Flugzeugboden durch. Ich habe oberhalb so viel Platz, dass ich da, wo der Kabinenboden ist, dass ich da oberhalb drüber bleiben kann, da nicht reingehen muss. So, dann zeigte sich aber schnell, wenn ich es vorne reinbaue, dann werde ich kopflastig. Ich muss also viel Ballastgewicht nach hinten reinbringen. Ein Flugzeug fliegt nicht, wenn es kopflastig ist. Oder nur sehr schwierig. Dann kommen sehr schnell instabile Flugbereiche. Das heißt, es sollte immer ein bisschen austariert sein. Der Schwerpunkt sollte auch in der Mitte vom Flugzeug liegen, ungefähr da, wo die Flügel sind. Und dann zeigt es sich, wenn man das vorne reinbaut, dann geht das mit der Nase nach unten. Also muss es nach hinten. Nach hinten, da ist halt der Rumpfdurchmesser kleiner. Andererseits ist er auch etwas kreisförmiger. Der Rumpfquerschnitt ist extrem oval. Wenn man jetzt da ein großes Loch reinschneidet, wo das Teleskop ausschaut, ist auch die Aerodynamik da. Sehr diffizil und das ist vor dem Flügel. Wie wirkt sich das aus? Hinter dem Flügel ist man schon etwas sicherer. Der Nachteil war, dass man dann aber durch den Kabinenboden durch muss, sonst kriegt man diese 2,50 m Spiegel da nicht mehr rein. Da hat man aber gesagt, das geht einfacher, als wenn es sich jetzt lässt machen.
Also bei dem KAO war ja die Öffnung vorne.
Ja, sie war zwar vorne, aber relativ nah am Flügel. Das KAO war ein Hochdecker, also die Flügel waren quasi unter dem, sondern oben am Flugzeug angemacht. Und das schaute da oben raus und hatte eben auch nur dieses 90 cm relativ kleines Fenster zum Rauschauen. Da ging das. Da war das möglich. Bei SOFIA, man fängt ja nicht gleich an zu bauen, sondern man macht verschiedene Vorphasen, untersucht dieses Konzept, jenes Konzept und untersucht das über Jahre, bis man glaubt, das Ideale gefunden zu haben. Es stellte sich eben raus, dass die hintere Position die günstiger war, aus diversen Gründen. Ein Grund zum Beispiel, das SOFIA Teleskop mit seinem Spiegel schaut ja durch eine Öffnung, durch ein Loch im Flugzeug, was völlig frei ist, keine Glasscheibe oder sonst was davor. Das würde ja die Infrarot-Strahlung blocken. Das muss man also voll im Freien rausschauen. Das heißt, es ist dort auch Umgebungstemperatur. Die Wissenschaftler selber in der Kabine sitzen bei normaler Flugzeugumgebung in Helmsermeln. Sie können dort ihre Instrumente betreiben und messen. Das heißt, ich brauche nur einen Druckschott einbauen. Ein druckdichtes Schott im Flugzeug. Hinter diesem Schott ist der Spiegel, der, wenn die Tür auf ist, in der freien Atmosphäre sich befindet, bei einem Drittel des Luftdrucks und bei minus 50 Grad. Wenn ich das Flugzeug jetzt von dem Druckschott bis vorne bis in die Pilotenkanzel, ist Eindruck. Wenn ich jetzt das Teleskop nach vorne mache, dann muss das Instrument hinter dem Teleskop angebracht sein. Ich brauche also zwei Druckschots, die das Teleskop abgrenzen. Die Wissenschaftler sitzen im hinteren Bereich, die Piloten vorne. Ich muss auch noch eine Verbindung zwischen denen haben. Im Notfall müssen sie hin und her laufen können. Oder einen Tunnel buddeln oder sonst was.
Also Sicherheitsgründe etc.
Beim KAO ging das, weil das Teleskop war da noch nicht so groß. Das füllte also nicht den gesamten Rumpfquerschnitt aus. Man konnte hinter dem Teleskop noch drum rumlaufen. Es war so eine Art Kapsel, die abgeschottet war. Man spart sich einen Druckshot. Das ist eine größere Geschichte vom Gewicht her und vom technologischen Aufwand. Dieses Druckshot schirmt also einmal die Kabine gegen den Außendruck ab und ist gleichzeitig auch der Befestigungspunkt vom Teleskop. Wenn wir über die Technik zu sprechen kommen, kann ich das gleich noch erläutern.
Dann sind wir ja im Prinzip schon mittendrin. Bleiben wir einfach mal bei dem Flugzeug. Also wir nehmen eine Boeing 747, die ist jetzt nicht neu bestellt worden, sondern das war schon eine, die schon ein bisschen länger im Einsatz ist. Das ist, glaube ich, ein relativ bekanntes Flugzeug.
Es hat einen bekannten Namen. Es war eine der ersten Boeing 747 SB. SB steht für Special Performance. Das ist eigentlich eine Standard-Boeing 747, die aber einen verkürzten Rumpf hat.
Also nicht so lang ist.
Nicht so lang ist. Da fehlt eine Mittelsektion. Section sowieso fehlt einfach. Die ist 1977 in Betrieb genommen worden von Penn M und auf den Namen Lindbergh getauft worden. Lindbergh war dieser Atlantik-Flieger Charles Lindbergh. Der hat es sicherlich selber auch noch getauft. Davon gehe ich mal aus, dass er dabei war.
Hat er darauf gelebt, dass es seine Frau war?
Das kann man schnell googeln. Dann ist es jahrelang bei Penn Am geflogen. Als Penn Am dann in Konkurs ging, hat, glaube ich, United Airlines das dann später geflogen. Ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, ab welchem Jahr, so etwa ab 1902, 93, 94, wurde es außer Dienst gestellt und in der trockenen Wüste in Kalifornien oder Nevada abgestellt. Das war die erste Änderung der gesamten Struktur des Flugzeugs. Dazu muss man sagen, dass in den frühen Phasen, wie gesagt, 1986, waren die ersten Gespräche, Überlegungen und Voruntersuchungen zwischen DLR und NASA und mit Industrie. Die Firma Boeing noch interessiert war und auch bereit gewesen wäre, das Flugzeug selber umzubauen. Aber so ab 1988, 89 hat Boeing gesagt, der Umbau von Einzelflugzeugen, der passt nicht in unsere Philosophie. Wir bauen Flugzeuge am Fließband, wir schieben fünf Boings durch unsere Hallen pro Monat durch und da stört unseren ganzen Ablauf. Das ist so, als wenn Sie Montageband bei VW jetzt plötzlich sagen, wir bauen jetzt zwischendurch mal einen alten Kamerangear, schieben wir da in das Fließbandrand. Das würde alles für Monate zusammenbrechen. Das geht gar nicht.
Das ist mehr wie so eine Tuning-Werkstatt, die sich darauf spezialisiert, dann eben die fertigen Modelle zu nehmen und dann wiederum in eine andere Version.
Und da gibt es weltweit wenige Firmen, die sowas machen. Die Hauptkunden sind oft Privatleute.
Die lassen sich dann ihre Superbar einbauen und so was.
Vermögende Firmenchefs oder auch Firmenflugzeug. Oder Präsidentenflugzeuge. Oder auch arabische Scheiß. Da gibt es etliche Beispiele, die gerade diese 747SP fliegen. Es gibt einige Firmen weltweit, die sich auf Einzelumbauten spezialisiert haben. Tuningfirmen, wie sie sagen. Unter anderem macht das auch die Lufthansa Technik in Hamburg. Die auch nicht im großen Stil, aber doch einzelne Flugzeuge nicht in dem Sinne wie SOFIA die ganze Struktur umbaut. Das ist im Wissen ja die Inneneinrichtung, die geändert wird. Für Firmenbosse, als Firmenflugzeuge oder für Regierungsflugzeuge. An der Struktur des Flugzeugs wird nichts geändert. Da wird kein Loch reingeschnitten. Die Elektronik wird vielleicht abgeändert, aber es ist die Innenausstattung. Bei SOFIA ist die große Herausforderung, dass ich ein Riesenloch in den Rumpf schneide. Man schneidet es nicht physikalisch rein, aber eine Riesenöffnung habe im Flug, die auch, wenn die Tür aufgeht, offen ist. Ein viermal vier Meter großes Loch. Und trotzdem soll dieses Flugzeug noch stabil fliegen.
Also Anforderungen an die Aerodynamik, an die Stabilität des Rumpfes?
Ja, wenn ich da so ein Loch im Rumpf habe, der Rumpf trägt massiv zur Stabilität eines Flugzeugs bei. Ein Flugzeug an solches ist ja relativ elastisch. Es ist ja nicht sehr steif. Man sieht das ja, wenn man fliegt, und wie die Triebwerke da rumwackeln und die Flügel hochgehen bei Turbulenzen. Deswegen fliegt ein Flugzeug und bricht nicht auseinander, weil es eben ein bisschen elastisch ist. Aufgrund, wie es in seiner warmen Struktur zusammengebaut ist. Ein Flugzeug wird heute noch gebaut wie Segelschiffe, mit Kiel und Spanten.
Luftschiff wäre eigentlich immer noch die bessere Bezeichnung.
Die Sprache ist auch noch so. Man redet also nicht von der... Der Kabinenboot, aber der Öde heißt Waterline. Das ist im Englischen Wasserlinie und nicht Luftlinie oder sonst was. Man verwendet die Begriffe aus der Seefahrt. Das Flugzeug fliegt auch mit Knoten. Die NASA selber hat das metrische Gestellung.
Ich meine, man schwimmt in der Luft. Es gibt ja genug Vergleiche.
Die große Herausforderung war... Ich hatte vorhin gesagt, dass die Firma Boeing am Anfang interessiert war und später nicht mehr. Sie war nachher auch so stark desinteressiert, dass sie auch die Kerndaten dieses Flugzeugs nicht an die Firma gegeben hat, die das Flugzeug dann wirklich umgebaut hat. Man hätte das für sehr taures Geld von der Firma Boeing kaufen müssen. Da hat die Firma L3 im texanischen Beko, die das Flugzeug umgebaut hat, gesagt, wir kriegen das billiger hin, wenn wir mehrere Wochen mit SOFIA fliegen, die ganzen Testflugmanöver machen, die jedes neue Flugzeug machen muss, und dabei messen, wie sich unser Flugzeug verhält. Das hat man verglichen mit Windkanalversuchen, die man gemacht hat, mit dem nicht modifizierten Flugzeug, 7% Modell, die NASA hat in Kalifornien sehr große Windkanäle, wo man das machen kann.
Also 7% der Größe.
7% der Größe, Entschuldigung, ja. Und hat dann diese Messdaten, die man im Flug gewonnen hat, mit den Windkanalversuchen verglichen, um das Modell, was man da im Windkanal hat, zu verifizieren, damit man das vergleichen kann. Und dann hat man das 7% Modell genommen, hat dann das Loch reingemacht, mal vorne, mal hinten, mit verschiedenen Spoilern usw. und hat entsprechende Windkanalversuche gemacht und hat das dann hochgerechnet, wie sich das auf das eigentliche SOFIA Flugzeug, das 100% SOFIA Flugzeug auswirken würde. Das sind alles rein mathematische Verfahren, die man da nutzt. Und durch diese Analogie-Vergleiche war man sich sicher, dass einmal die Rechenmodelle stimmen. Und dann hat man diese Rechenmodelle auf das modifizierte SOFIA Flugzeug angewendet und hat festgestellt, ja, das ist machbar. So ein Loch reinzuschneiden, das mit einer Tür abzuschließen und dann auch im Flug die Tür zu öffnen, ohne dass der Flieger auseinanderbricht oder vom Himmel fällt.
Und zwar ohne jetzt nennenswerte Änderungen wirklich zu dem Flugzeugdesign zu machen.
Man hat, man muss im Inneren, man muss einmal dieses Druckschott einbauen. Dieses Druckschott geht ja über den ganzen, also eine Wand sozusagen, einfach den vorderen, den hinteren Bereich einfach trennt. Eine dicke Wand.
Wie dick ist die?
Die ist etwa 60 Zentimeter dick. Ist nicht massiv, sondern wie im Flugzeugbau üblich, aus Spanten und Aluminiumpanelen usw. Und so eine geschlossene Wand versteift natürlich auch schon den Rumpf. Das kompensiert in etwa die Öffnung. Dann hat man um die Öffnung herum die Beplankung verdickt und all das versteift dann auch diese Öffnung, sodass das nicht stärker rotiert und schwingt wie vorher. Das sind sehr massive Änderungen. Wo man relativ wenig machen musste, war an der Aerodynamik. Man musste also jetzt nicht vorne so eine Spoiler machen, sondern man hat stattdessen... Also typischerweise, wenn Luft über so eine Kante strömt, dann ist es charakteristisch mit, glaube ich, einem Winkel von 7,5 Grad kippt sozusagen der Strom ab und würde ins Innere dieser Cavity dieses Lochs reinströmen und dann hinten auf das hintere Shot treffen. Das darf natürlich nicht sein. Also hat man im hinteren Bereich so eine Art Rampe angebracht, wo sich der Luftstrom anschmiecht und dann sanft wieder rausgeht. Das hat sich dann bei dem ganzen Fluchtest gezeigt, dass sich das prima bewährt. Also ich hatte die Gelegenheit, einmal auf dem KAO zu fliegen und im Dezember auch erst einmal auf dem SOFIA. Auf dem KAO ist mir in Erinnerung geblieben, wenn man die Tür aufgemacht hat, hat man das am Flugzeug gemerkt, wie es anfing zu rappeln und man hat es auch gehört. Wenn bei SOFIA die Tür aufgeht, merken nicht mal die Piloten was.
Das ist ein bisschen vergleichbar zu so Cabrios. Wenn man jetzt das Dach aufmacht, dann hat man dasselbe Problem. Und vorne ist ja dann erst einmal die Windschutzscheibe, die macht das ja hoch. Dann hat man aber trotzdem noch diese Verwirbelungsprobleme gehabt. Und dann kam, glaube ich, irgendwann Mercedes vor einigen Jahren mit dieser Idee, hinten einfach auch nochmal so ein Netz eigentlich nur noch aufzubauen und damit war dann ziemliche Windstille.
Vielleicht kann man es besser mit einem Schiebedach vergleichen, weil das ist eine kleinere Öffnung. Und wenn Sie im Auto Ihr Schiebedach aufmachen und fahren über die Autobahn mit 100 km.
Dann kommt ja auch so eine kleine Lippe hoch.
Man kann diese Lippe quasi auch nach hinten verlegen, dann geht sie aber nach unten und führt den Luftschirm raus. Und Sie merken auch, wenn Sie im Auto mit offenem Verdeck fahren und halten die Handrausung oder klappen diese Lippe runter, dann hören Sie sofort die Vibration. Das ist natürlich im SOFIA Flugzeug auch noch. Wenn die Tür aufgeht, haben Sie diesen Orgelpfeifeneffekt, dass da so Schwingungen auftreten. Aber der Luftstrom selber, der geht nicht rein oder nur ganz gering. Wenn der Luftstrom direkt 800 kmh, selbst in der dünnen Luft, massiv auf die Teleskopstruktur trifft, dann können Sie das Teleskop nicht mehr ausrichten und stabilisieren. Das heißt, der Luftstrom darf das Teleskop nicht treffen.
Das heißt, in dem geöffneten Bereich ist vielleicht nicht gerade Windstille, aber da sind zumindest keine erheblichen Turbulenzen?
Das sind geringe Turbulenzen, aber kein direkter Luftstrom. Es ist mehr so ein Schwingungseffekt wie so ein Flöteneffekt oder wie eine Orgelpfeife.
Aber das erzeugt ja dann immer noch Vibrationen. Das ist ja jetzt für so ein Messgerät nicht unbedingt die optimale Bedingung.
Das ist tödlich. Die Astronomen heute Tage wollen ihren Teleskop ungestört auf einen Stern oder auf eine Molekülwolke oder auf einen bestimmten Punkt ausrichten, ohne dass sich das auch nur mindestens bewegt.
Das Flugzeug an sich ist ja auch eine einzige Vibrationsmaschine. Düsen sind da am Start, es flattert im Wind. Das heißt, das ist alles gelagert. Das schwimmt alles in Öl oder was?
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Der Schwimmt in Öl. Die Idee, die sich dann herauskristallisiert hat, das Design, was man dann auch realisiert hat, ist eine Art Hantel-Design. Eine Hantel besteht aus einem zentralen Rohr mit zwei Kugeln an jedem Ende.
Also wir reden jetzt von so einem Gewichtshantel.
Ja, und das zentrale Rohr, das gibt es bei SOFIA auch. Und die beiden Kugeln am Ende ist einmal auf der hinteren Seite das Teleskop mit seinen Spiegeln. Und auf der vorderen Seite ist es quasi das Instrument. Und die Besonderheit bei dieser SOFIA-Hantel ist noch, dass es noch eine dritte kleine Kugel in der Mitte vom Rohr hat oder im Schwerpunkt. So eine Kugelkalotte. Und diese Kugel im Zentrum, die ist in einer Kugelschale gelagert, die sich in diesem Ruckshot befindet. Und diese Kugel bewegt sich in dieser Kugelschale wie so ein Kniegelenk oder Hüftgelenk. In allen drei Richtungen frei rotieren kann. Und der Spalt zwischen dieser zentralen Kugel und der Kugelschale, in der es ruht, der ist wenige Mikrometer, also hundertstel Millimeter. Etwa so hat etwa die Dicke eines Platzpapiers. Und das über einen Umfang, durchmesser der Kugel von 1,20 Meter. Und in diesen Spalt, da wird mit hohem Druck Öl reingepresst. Und dadurch habe ich quasi ein nahezu reibungsloses Rotationsverhalten. Das heißt, ich habe eine Kugel, die sich in einer Kugelschale völlig frei rotieren kann. Dieses Öl ist, das wissen Sie selber, wenn Sie irgendwo auf einer Ölspur geraten, dann haben Sie keine Reibungen mehr. Dann rutschen Sie wie auf nassem Eis. Wie auf Öl halt. Auf diese Art und Weise ist es so, dass das bewegliche Teil des Teleskop mit seinen 8 Tonnen auf irgendeinen Stern schaut. Jetzt rotiert das Flugzeug ein bisschen drumrum. Da es aber keine Reibung hat, folgt das Teleskop diesen Flugzeugbewegungen nicht, durch seine Trägheit in erster Näherung. Das heißt, das Flugzeug rotiert immer leicht, schwingt immer ganz leicht von links nach rechts. Das sieht man, wenn man auf so einen Flügel schaut. Davon merkt eigentlich das Teleskop gar nichts, weil es reibungsfrei in dieser Kugel gelagert ist und es eigentlich gar nicht registrieren würde. Es ist natürlich so, dass es immer noch eine gewisse Restreibung gibt. Ich habe überall Kabel rumhängen, sodass das Teleskop natürlich trotzdem gestört würde. Dazu habe ich elektromagnetische Antriebe, die berührungsfrei arbeiten. Ich habe also Spulen und Magnete. Und wenn ich Strom durch diese Spulen schicke, habe ich ein magnetisches Feld, was sich dann entweder anzieht oder...
Wie so ein Lautsprecher funktioniert.
In ähnlicher Form, ja, genau. Und damit kann ich dann das Teleskop auch in Rotation steuern. So, das andere sind Vibrationen. Die gehen natürlich durch so einen Lager nicht durch. Wenn das ganze Flugzeug wackelt, wäre es auch in erster Nährung erst mal nicht schlimm, wenn so ein Flugzeug zehn Meter durchsackt. Wenn es einfach gradlinig durchsackt. Ich schaue ja mit meinem Teleskop auf ein unendlich weit entferntes Objekt, eine Sternengalaxie, die ist ewig weit weg. Wenn ich jetzt mein Flugzeug zehn Meter tiefer setze, schaut es immer noch auf das gleiche Objekt. Ich darf nur keine Rotationsbewegungen reinbringen. Das heißt, Vibrationen würden in erster Nährung auch nicht stören, weil sie nur laterale Bewegungen machen. Allerdings führen sie natürlich dazu, dass diese Vibrationen das zentrale Rohr sozusagen verbiegen oder auch die Teleskopstruktur verbiegen würden. Und dann habe ich natürlich, wenn ich eine Verbiegung habe, habe ich auch eine Drehbewegung am Himmel. Die darf nicht sein. Also ist der ganze Mechanismus dieses Öllager, einschließlich Teleskops, auf einem Federsystem gelagert. Das müssen Sie sich vorstellen wie Lkw-Federn. Es gibt diese Luftfedern, das sind diese donatförmigen, schwarzen Gummibelge, die man so etwa sieht. Und diese federn das Ganze ab. Dann gibt es noch Schwierungsdämpfer. Es ist im Prinzip wie eine Autoaufhängung oder beim Lkw. Ist dieses gesamte Teleskop in diesem, in dieser Wand, in diesem Druckschott vom Flugzeug gelagert?
Aber man kann jetzt die beliebige, ich meine, man kennt das ja so aus dem Flugzeug, dann kommt dann einfach mal so eine Thermik oder so ein Loch und dann, dann geht es wirklich bergab. Also irgendwo ist auch Schluss. Aber bis zu welchem Maße kann jetzt diese Federung das alles kompensieren?
Also das, theoretisch sollte es bis zu einem halben G sein an Beschleunigungswerten. Also bei milder Turbulenz, wie man so sagt, sollte es noch funktionieren. Und es hat ein Messloh gegeben im April, bei dem man durch heftiges Wetter geflogen ist, ein bisschen unerwarteterweise, weil die Vorhersagen, also selbst in der Höhe, war noch Turbulenz. Und die Wissenschaftler und Techniker und Ingenieure an Bord mussten sich anschnallen auf Kommando des Piloten. Und das Teleskop hat ungerührt weiter beobachtet. Aber das ist so in der Grenzbereich. Aber man hat den Vorteil, dass man gerade in der zweiten Hälfte, wenn ein Großteil des Treibstoffverbrauchs ist, auf sehr große Höhen gehen kann, bis zu 14 Kilometer. Und da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man in solche Turbulenzen kommt, schon deutlich geringer. Das ist auch der Vorteil, dass man sehr hoch fliegt und in der Regel außerhalb vom normalen Wettergeschehen sich befindet.
14 Kilometer, das ist das Maximum?
14 ist das Maximum, ja.
Aber am Anfang muss man tiefer fliegen?
Am Anfang kommt man nicht so hoch, weil das Flugzeug so schwer ist. Man kann natürlich sagen, ich lade nur die halbe Menge Treibstoff zu, dann kann ich direkt auf große Höhen fliegen. Aber die Wissenschaftler können, das ist jetzt jahreszeitlich und wetterbedingt, dazu muss ich sagen, der Wasserdampf in der Atmosphäre, der das begrenzende Element ist. Wenn ich zu viel Wasserdampf habe, kommt meine Infrarot-Strahlung nicht mehr durch. Und dieser Wasserdampf nimmt nicht gleichmäßig ab, sondern es gibt eine sogenannte Grenzschicht, eine Tropopause, unterhalb derer sich das gesamte Wettergeschehen abspiegelt. Und diese Tropopause ist eine scharfe Grenzschicht. Ab da ist der Wasserdampfradikal fast auf Null gesetzt, nicht ganz. Und ich muss oberhalb dieser Tropopause sein. Und die ist jahreszeitlich variabel. Im Sommer ist sie höher, weil es einfach wärmer ist. Das sieht man in Gewitterwolken, die sind im Sommer hoch. Und im Äquatorbereich ist sie höher, weil sich da mehr Wärme entwickelt. Und im Polarbereich ist sie geringer. Aber wenn ich oberhalb dieser Tropopause bin, diese Tropopause schwankt eben zwischen 11 und 14 Kilometer Höhe. Und wenn ich meine Flugplanung geschickt auslege, und ich bin am Anfang noch voll mit Treibstoff und komme nur 37.000 Fuß, 10, 11 Kilometer hoch, fange ich aber im Norden an oder in einem Gebiet, wo die Tropopause niedriger ist, kann ich trotzdem schon was messen. Und jede Stunde kann ich dann einen halben Kilometer höher. Und komme in immer bessere Klinken. Manche Instrumente können auch in 37.000 Fuß, kriegen 50 Prozent der Energie reingestrahlt, fangen dann schon an zu messen, damit sie überhaupt was haben. Und wenn nach 3, 4 Stunden ist man auf 45.000 Fuß, dann kriegen sie 90 Prozent rein und verbessern halt ihre Sammelfähigkeit.
Ja, wir hatten ja hier vor einigen Ausgaben auch eine Sendung zur Atmosphäre, wo es auch viel um die Aschewolke, Messungen ging und so weiter, aber wo auch so diese Atmosphärenstruktur eine Rolle gespielt hat. Wer da anschließen möchte, kann sich auch nochmal in die Sendung reinhören, wenn das noch nicht schon geschehen ist. 14 Kilometer, das ist natürlich schon deutlich höher, auch als der normale Flugverkehr so operiert. Man befindet sich wirklich so am niedrigsten Bereich der Stratosphäre. Das muss ja auch sein, weil sonst wäre der Name ja falsch gewesen.
Richtig, die Tropopause grenzt gerade die Troposphäre, wo das Wetter geschehen, Wolken sich abspielt von der Stratosphäre ab. Und deswegen stratosphärig, weil es genau am unteren Rand der Stratosphäre lang kratzt. Die Flieger messen ja alles in Fuß. Das sind jetzt nicht exakt, da müsste ich jetzt genau umrechnen, 14,2. Die Angabe in Fuß sind 45.000 Fuß. Diese Limitierung hängt von dem SOFIA Flugzeug ab. Es kann halt nicht höher fliegen.
Wo ist denn so die Grenze da?
Es gibt ja Forschungsflugzeuge der NASA und inzwischen auch vom DLR, die im Bereich bis zu 16, 18, 20 Kilometer Höhe fliegen können. Und zwar auch beständig. Also auch dieses Spionageflugzeug, die U2, konnte glaube ich auch über 14 Kilometer höher. Ich kenne die genauen Zahlen nicht. Die NASA verwendet übrigens immer noch diese U2-Flugzeuge in modifizierter Form auch als Forschungsflugzeuge, um in solch großen Höhen Aerosole einzeln zu sammeln, Vulkanasche, so wie es das DLR mit dem Vulkanjäger oder Vulkanjäger, glaube ich, Falcon gemacht hat. Das DLR hat ja ein neues zusätzliches Forschungsflugzeug vor eineinhalb Jahren bekommen, das HALO, High Altitude. Das ist gerade dabei mit entsprechenden Messinstrumenten ausgestattet zu werden. Die HALO kann auch bis 18 in dem Bereich fliegen. Es gibt natürlich Flugzeuge...
High Altitude and Long Range Research Aircraft. Natürlich auch gerade mal nachgeschrieben. Geistream G550 Flugzeug. Also das U2 schafft tatsächlich 20 Kilometer.
Es gibt Flugzeuge, die für eine Kurzsitzung... Also es hat immer diese amerikanischen, die ersten Astronautenkandidaten...
Das HALO macht 15...
.sind mit Starfightern bis 80 Kilometer hochgeflogen. Also das hat man viel anrufgenommen und ist dann hoch. Und dann ist man auch wieder runtergefahren.
Na gut, wenn nicht 10 Stunden lang rumfliegen.
Nee, also das sind ein paar Minuten, dann fiel man wieder runter.
Und schon gar nicht so viel Last mitnehmen.
Und manche sind in der Tat untergefallen, bis unten auf dem Boden, weil in der großen Höhe oft dann auch die Triebwerke ausgesetzt haben und nicht wieder ansprangen. Und wenn so ein Flugzeug einmal in so einem Spinn ist, dann kann man das nicht mehr stabilisieren. Dann fällt das runter und dann... Ja, aber das ist nur so kurz so recht.
Wäre denn das noch erstrebenswert, die Flughöhe noch weiter zu steigern? Ich meine, wie viel Prozent des Wassers hat man dann schon unter sich gelassen, wenn man so weit ist? 99 Prozent.
Wenn man überhaupt der Tropopause ist. Also die Höhe steigern würde Sinn machen, wenn man am Anfang mit voller Treibstoffzuladung direkt auf großer Höhe...
Also man sozusagen nicht......
oberhalb von 45.000 Fuß das zu steigern bringt, nur in Ausnahmefällen etwas. Das gibt das eine oder andere Instrument. Man mag da noch ein paar Prozentpünktchen gewinnen, aber das wäre die zusätzlichen Kosten nicht wert. Also es gibt kein Flugzeug der Größenordnung, wie dieser Boeing 747, wie dieser fliegen kann. Man müsste ein völlig neues Flugzeug entwickeln. Neues Flugzeug entwickeln, das sind mehrere Milliarden Euro.
Könnte man nicht so eine verkürzte Version von dem A380 nehmen, dass man da noch was reinschnippelt?
Muss man mal schauen, wie sich das bei Airbus weiterentwickelt. Das ist jetzt die A380 600 oder wie sie heißt, ist das erste Modell und nach 30 Jahren haben sich daraus 15 weitere Modelle entwickelt.
Das kann durchaus passieren.
Es wird mich nicht wundern, wenn nach 10 Jahren SOFIA Betrieb die Astronomen sagen, wunderschönes Ding, aber 8 Meter Spiegel wäre noch besser.
Das Ding ist im Wesentlichen rund und über die ganze Breite, da wäre sicherlich noch einiges zu holen.
Ich will jetzt nicht die Erwartungen wecken, dass das DLR gerade Geld sammelt, um so NASA...
Na gut, aber man steht ja jetzt mit SOFIA auch noch ganz am Anfang. Der Regelbetrieb ist ja auch überhaupt nicht aufgenommen worden, sondern wir reden jetzt, es gab zwar schon Flüge, aber ich weiß nicht, in welchem Modus befindet sich das Projekt. Vielleicht auch noch mal kurz so etwas zu dieser, ich weiß nicht, ob wir diese Entstehungsgeschichte schon richtig abgebildet haben. Also NASA hat es halt vorher alleine gemacht, hat dann gesehen, okay, wir haben jetzt auch gar nicht jetzt die... Also es gibt Instrumente, die übertreffen das, was wir jetzt selber im Einsatz haben, noch so sehr, dass wir das auch unbedingt haben wollen. Dann gab es diese Einladung und daraus hat sich dann diese Kooperation dann entwickelt, dass man gesagt hat, okay, die nächste Generation, die machen wir dann auch gleich gemeinsam. Das heißt, bei der SOFIA ist es so, dass das Flugzeug und der Betrieb, das ist quasi der Teil der NASA und alles jenseits des Druckshots ist DLR. Kann man das so verkürzen oder trifft es das nicht so richtig?
Ja, nicht so ganz. Im Prinzip ist schon eine Aufteilung, aber wir wollten eigentlich ein seamless Team, dass es da nicht so getrennt hergeht. Die Entwicklung war so, dass nachdem die deutschen Wissenschaftler auf den KAO geflogen sind, dem DLR die Tür eingerannt sind, sagen wir müssen unbedingt bei der NASA mitmachen. Das ist ein tolles Potential für die Astrophysik, für die Astronomie. Wir haben auch die entsprechenden Detektoren und Instrumente, die wir entwickeln werden. Das hat Zukunft dieses Gebiet. Und NASA hat sich dann auch ans DLR gewandt. Und auch in Kenntnis der Technologien, die in Deutschland auf dem Gebiet von Großteleskopen fahren sind. Also Namen wie die Firma Zeiss waren ja nun weltbekannt. Die haben sehr viele bodengebundete Teleskope bis 3,60 Meter gebaut. Und die Europäer haben 8-Meter-Spiegel in Chile gebaut. Das heißt, da war ein großes Know-how in Europa und Deutschland. Man hätte ja auch sagen können, die Deutschen bauen das Flugzeug um, und die Amerikaner bauen das Teleskop. Nein, es war so, dass die Amerikaner, die NASA meinte, das wäre ein Gebiet, wo die Deutschen sehr kompetent sind. Und das war mit ein Grund für diese Aufteilung. Dann hat es natürlich lange Diskussionen, Verhandlungen gegeben. Eigentlich, das DLR macht ja Raumfahrt. Und SOFIA Flugzeug ist ja nun keine Raumfahrt. Die DFG, die Max-Bank-Gesellschaft, nutzen bodengebundene Teleskope. Diese Auftrennung war sauber. Aber wer macht flugzeuggetragene Astrometer? Da gibt es ja niemanden. Und dann hat sich das DLR und die Ministerien überreden lassen und sagen, wir machen das ja mit NASA zusammen. NASA ist Luft- und Raumfahrt. Also der natürliche Ansprechpartner auf deutscher Seite für die NASA wäre das DLR. SOFIA ist von der Komplexität und vergleichbar einem Satellitenprojekt. Also sollte es eigentlich das DLR machen. Und das war dann die Entscheidung, die im Ministerium getroffen wurde. Ich glaube schon die Anfänge 85, 86, 87. Und wir haben dann mit der NASA erste Abstimmung gemacht. Da macht man so einen Briefaustausch und Letter-Agreement, wo jede Seite festlegt, was sie macht, was die andere Seite macht, damit man auch sauber die Aufgaben trennt. Und auf dieser Basis haben wir dann in Deutschland sogenannte Machbarkeitsuntersuchungen durchführen lassen. Das DLR hat Aufträge an deutsche Firmen vergeben, die diese Untersuchungen gemacht haben. Man teilt zu Projekte immer in Phasen ein. Die werden mit Buchstaben bezeichnet, Phase A, B, CD. Phase E ist der Betrieb. Phase A ist Machbarkeitsuntersuchung. Phase B ist vorläufige Designuntersuchung. Die Phase CD ist die Herstellphase. Wir haben es bis 1989 hier in Deutschland geschafft, die Phasen A und B durchzuführen. Wir hatten am Ende von 89 eigentlich ein Konzept, wie man das jetzt bauen könnte. Das ist das eine. Das zweite, was man braucht, sind die finanziellen Ressourcen. Die müssen dann zeitgleich auf amerikanischer und auf deutscher Seite Geld vorhanden sein, damit jeder seinen Teil machen kann. Und dann kam 1989-90 die Deutsche Vereinigung dazwischen. Viel Geld im DLR aus den Ministerien wurde in die ostdeutschen Institute gesteckt, um die am Leben zu erhalten. Sodass da eine Lücke war, wo wir gar nicht die finanziellen Mittel hatten, um SOFIA zu machen. Andere Dinge waren auch schon länger in Vorbereitung gewesen. Die macht man natürlich zuerst ab. Aber da arbeitet man zuerst ab und man muss sich dann hinten anstellen. Dann zeigte sich dann, dass wir mal kein Geld hatten. Dann gab es Seiten, 92, 93 hatten wir wieder Geld, aber die NASA gerade keins. Und dann gab es 95, ein kleines Fenster, wo es parallel allen gut ging. Und wir beide Geld hatten. Und sagten, unter diesen Voraussetzungen können wir es machen. Und dann haben NASA und DLR ein sogenanntes Memorandum of Understanding geschlossen. Das ist eine Art Vereinbarung. Es gibt ja keine Verträge zwischen NASA und DLR, sondern man kann nur Vereinbarungen treffen, die sind nicht rechtsverbindlich oder einklagbar. Das ist immer best effort. Aber da wurde dann genau die Verantwortung aufgeteilt. Und dort wurde festgelegt, NASA kauft das Flugzeug, modifiziert es und integriert das deutsche Teleskop in dieses Flugzeug. Die deutsche Seite, das DLR, ist verantwortlich für den Bau des Teleskops und die Beistellung an die NASA und unterstützt die Integration ins Flugzeug. Und das wurde damals mal ganz grob abgeschätzt. Das wäre dann ungefähr der deutsche Anteil, finanziell wären dann etwa 20% und der amerikanische Anteil 80%. Dann haben wir gesagt, gut, dann verteilen wir auch die wissenschaftliche Nutzung. Dann bekommen auch die Deutschen 20% der Messzeit und die Amerikaner 80% der Messzeit. Aber nur, wenn die deutsche Seite auch 20% der Betriebskosten übernimmt. Und das haben wir dann so vereinbart. Und dann haben wir noch zusätzlich vereinbart, dass wir nicht der NASA einmal im Jahr 20% des Geldes überweisen, sondern wir haben damals festgelegt, das ungefähr ist der Anteil an Personal, der benötigt wird auf amerikanischer Seite, und das sind die 20% auf deutscher Seite. Also das ist unser Betriebsbeitrag, den wir in Sachleistungen erbringen, in kind, wie es so schön heißt. Also in Form von Personal oder Reparatur, Wartungsarbeiten am Teleskop, Ersatzteile. Wir haben dann gesagt, wir machen sogar die Triebwerkswartung, ist Teil unserer Aufgabe. Und diesen speziellen Punkt haben wir dann später dadurch gelöst, dass wir moderne, also überholte Triebwerke beschafft haben. Und damit quasi unseren Betriebsbeitrag bezüglich Triebwerkswartung für die nächsten 20 Jahre schon abgedeckt hatten. Da haben wir also am Anfang viel Geld investiert, statt 20 Jahre lang wenig. Das war natürlich ein Risiko. Wenn das Projekt nicht zum Tragen kommt, ist das Geld vergeblich gewesen. Aber diese Triebwerke könnte man heute, glaube ich, mit Gewinn gut wieder verkaufen, weil sie gefragt sind. Weil diese 747 SB läuft langsam aus. Und Ersatzteile zu beschaffen, ist schwierig. Zurück zu der Vereinbarung. Das wurde damals vereinbart. Und unabhängig, wie sich das jetzt über die Jahre entwickelt, also wenn jetzt NASA plötzlich doppelt so viel Geld ausgeben muss, um das Flugzeug umzubauen, dann heißt es nicht, dass sie plötzlich 90 % und wir nur noch 10 % haben, sondern es bleibt bei dieser 20-80-Regelung. Egal, wie teuer es für eine Seite wird. Weil sonst würde man ständig versuchen, gegeneinander aufzurechnen, wir haben mal mehr ausgegeben, wir wollen 10 Stunden mehr Messzeit. Sondern, dass man grundsätzlich diese Vereinbarung hat. Das ist wichtig. Auf dieser Basis haben wir dann in Deutschland Ende 1996, Anfang 1997, im Auftrag an die deutsche Industrie vergeben, zu bauen dieses Teleskops. Dieser Auftrag erfolgte nach Wettbewerbsverfahren. Wir hatten also zwei Firmenkonsortien, die uns interessante Vorschläge gemacht haben, wie es zu bauen ist. Und da haben wir das wirtschaftlichste von ausgewählt. So hatten wir also eine gewisse Konkurrenzsituation. Das ist natürlich immer schön, wenn man das hat. Oft hat man in der Raumfahrt nur eine Firma, die anbietet. Da muss man eben frisst oder stirbt. Und hier waren wir in der glücklichen Situation, dass wir hier zwei Firmenkonsortien hatten, die beide sehr gute Angebote eingeladen haben.
Wer hat das Land in Deutschland umgesetzt?
Die Firmen, die das gewonnen haben, waren ein Konsortium aus den damaligen Firmen MAN Technologie und Kaisertrede, MAN Technologie in Mainz, Augsburg, und Kaisertrede GmbH in München. Die Firma MAN Technologie ist zwischenzeitlich umbenannt in MT Mechatronics und Teil des OHB-Konzerns in Bremen. Und auch die Firma Kaisertrede ist vor einigen Jahren von der Firma OHB mit aufgekauft worden, zumindest teilweise. Aber die beiden fungieren noch unter ihrem alten Namen. Die Firma jetzt, die Firma MT Mechatronics, war sehr erfahren auf dem Gebiet von großen Radioteleskopen. Sie kommen von der Gute-Hoffnungshütte in Oberhausen, MAN, LKW, also Schwermaschinenbau. Und haben das aber im Laufe der Jahre in bestimmten Sparten weiterentwickelt zum Leichtbau. Filigrane Radioteleskop-Strukturen. Sie haben Brücken gebaut, filigrane, und haben sich dann auch später auf modernere Materialien wie Kohlenfaser-Kunststoffe verlegt, die man aus dem Formel-1-Bau kennt, diese Monocox. Genau das wird bei SOFIA sehr viel eingesetzt.
Super stabil und sehr leicht.
Super stabil und vergleichsweise leicht. Im Vergleich zu Stahl, selbst Aluminium. Diese Firmen haben den Auftrag bekommen und hatten bis 2002 Zeit, das zu bauen und in die USA zu liefern. Wir haben etwa ein Jahr Zeitverzug reinbekommen. Sie haben es nicht exakt pünktlich abgeliefert. Das ist bei so etwas auch nicht zu erwarten. Das war schon eine technologische Herausforderung. Ich hätte schon mal gesagt, der Spiegel ist dreimal größer als beim KAO. Man darf, um Gottes Willen, nicht das achtfache Gewicht reinbringen, sondern man muss da schon wirklich neue Technologien einbringen.
Wo wir jetzt auf das eigentliche Teleskop nochmal zu sprechen kommen. Mich würde ja nochmal genau interessieren, was da jetzt eigentlich wirklich drin ist in dem Flugzeug, also wie das Flugzeug selber aufgebaut wurde, um überhaupt den Platz zu machen mit dem Druckshot. Das ist ja, glaube ich, ganz gut klar geworden. Aber woraus besteht denn jetzt dieses Teleskop tatsächlich? Also es gibt einen großen Spiegel. Wie muss man sich den vorstellen? Ist das so eine große Schüssel wie so eine Satellitenschüssel oder hat so ein Infrarotspiegel ganz andere Anforderungen? Ist das wirklich jetzt so ein Spiegel im Sinne von Spiegel? Wenn ich mich da vorstelle, sehe ich mich? Oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Ja, gut, ich hole mal ein bisschen aus. Es ist in der Tat ein Spiegel. Er besteht aus einer Glaskeramik. Diese Glaskeramik ist vergleichbar dem, was man zu Hause am Ceran Kochfeld hat. Das ist ein ähnliches Material. Nennt sich Serodur und hat einen ganz geringen Wärmeausdehnungs-Keffizienten. Das heißt, wenn die Temperaturen rauf und runter gehen, dehnt der Spiegel sich nicht aus und schrumpft auch nicht. Das heißt, der ist formstabil. Wenn Sie einen Aluminium-Spiegel haben, der verformt sich bei Temperaturschwankungen und dann wandert der Fokus aus. Dieser Serodur-Spiegel ist von der Firma Schott in Mainz und war ein Probespiegel gewesen für die 8,2-Meter-Spiegel der ESO in Chile, für das Very Large Teleskop. Dort hat die ESO vier 8-Meter-Spiegel.
Die ESO?
Die European Southern Observatory. Das ist eine ähnliche Organisation wie die ESA, aber für bodengebundene Teleskope. Der hatte 4 Meter Durchmesser und war 40 cm dick und wog 4 t, war also so nicht einsetzbar, weil er zu schwer war. Dann kann man erst mal auf die 2,70 Meter runterbringen, dann verliert man schon etliche Sattenmasse. Aber das ist immer noch viel zu schwer. Was macht man in dem Falle? Man hat das Verfahren gewählt, dass man von der Rückseite dieses Blocks Taschen reingefräst hat, sodass der Spiegel anschließend eine Art Warmenstruktur hat. Sechseckige Taschen von hinten, 122 oder 128 Stück, die aber nicht bis zur Oberfläche durchgefräst werden, sondern dass eine glatte, durchgängige Oberfläche, also quasi eine Deckplatte von zwei Zentimetern, stehen bleibt. Der Spiegel verliert kaum an Steifigkeit durch dieses Leichtgewichten, wie man das nennt. Aber er wird eben deutlich leichter. Der leicht gewichtete Spiegel wiegt noch 800 Kilogramm im Vergleich zu den 4000, die er ursprünglich hatte, ohne dass er an Stabilität wesentlich verloren hat.
Weil nach vorne ist es eigentlich ein durchgehender Spiegel.
Nach vorne ist es ein durchgehender Spiegel, glattes Schüssel. Und es sind von hinten so Sacktaschen eingefräst, sodass dünne Stege übrig bleiben.
So eine Wabenstruktur, die das sehr stabil hält.
Wenn man sich das Hubble Space Teleskop mit seinem Spiegel anschaut, der hat auch diese Wabenstruktur. Da hat man aber diese Stege aus jeweils drei Segmenten zusammengesetzt, dass man so eine Dreieckstruktur hat. Und hat dann oben drauf eine Platte draufgeklebt. Und hier hat man aus einem monolithischen Block heraus, das sozusagen rausgefräst. So ein Spiegel muss natürlich auch gehalten werden. Das heißt, der hat 18 Unterstützungspunkte, die in der Richtung nach oben halten und 6 an der Seite, sodass er sich nicht drehen kann. Und diese Unterstützungspunkte sind hinten wieder in eine Tragestruktur eingebaut. Das nennt man die Spiegelzelle. Und die wiegt auch noch wieder 800 Kilogramm. Und diese Spiegelzelle ist in einem Strebengerüst verbunden mit einem zweiten, dem Sekundärspiegel, der etwa 3 Meter oberhalb dieses Primärspiegels sich befindet und 30 Zentimeter Durchmesser hat. Das heißt, die Photonen, das Licht, was auf den Hauptspiegel trifft, wird gebündelt auf diesen zweiten Spiegel, der 3 Meter oberhalb von dieser Schüssel ist, und schickt das Licht wieder zurück, bis etwa 1 Meter oberhalb vom Hauptspiegel. Und dort befindet sich ein 45 Grad Plan-Spiegel, der das Licht im rechten Winkel durch dieses zentrale Rohr, dieses Handelrohr, nach vorne durch das Druckshot in die Kabine schickt. Und dort ist ein Fenster oder das Instrument ist dort angeflanscht, wo der Detektor sich befindet, wo das Licht auf diesen Detektor trifft. Und dann muss halt das Instrument auch druckdicht sein, sodass diese Druckdichtigkeit innerhalb der Kabine gewährleistet ist.
Das Ganze ist ja so eine... Man misst eigentlich nur einen einzigen Punkt. Also man misst wirklich nur eine einzige Quelle. Es ist jetzt nicht so ein zweidimensionales Bild, was man da abgreift?
Das hängt jetzt vom Experiment ab. Ich kann das vergleichen mit einer Kleingildkamera, die ich habe. Da ist ja heutzutage auch ein CCD-Shift drin, mit einer großen Linse vorneweg. Und hier benutzt man statt der Linse eben einen Spiegel. Und da können Sie auch flächige Abbildungen mitmachen. Wenn man jetzt einen Spektrometer hat, ein Gerät, was nur einen Detektor hat und was eine bestimmte Linie aufmisst, das misst in der Tat nur einen Punkt. Wenn ich da ein flächiges Bild haben will, dann muss ich eben diese Rastascans machen, dieses Scanning, um aus verschiedenen Punkten eben eine Art Bild zusammenzusetzen.
So ist das hier auch?
So ist das bei den Spektrometern auch. Und wenn ich eine Kamera verwende, die viele Pixel hat, dann habe ich ja jeder Pixel schaut auf eine kleine andere Stelle am Himmel. Also jeder Pixel in meinem CCD oder Infrarot-CCDs, das sind keine CCDs, aber vergleichbare Detektoren, schauen auf einen anderen Punkt am Himmel. Das ist wie bei jeder anderen Kamera auch. Gut, aber wie gesagt, noch mal zurück auf die Spiegel zu kommen.
Aber hier ist es nicht so. Also hier ist sozusagen der...
Sowohl als auch. Das hängt jetzt vom Instrument ab, mit was, womit ich beobachte. Ach so. Wenn ich nur einen Ein-Pixel-Detektor habe, dann sehe ich auch nur am Himmel eine Stelle. Wenn ich jetzt so zehn mal zehn Pixel nebeneinander habe, dann kann ich diese zehn mal zehn Pixel auch quasi am Himmel abbilden. Dann habe ich am Himmel ein Abbild von diesem zehn mal zehn Pixel. Dann messe ich also auch zehn mal zehn Punkte am Himmel. Die liegen natürlich sehr eng zusammen. Das ist also ein ganz enger Bereich. Und moderne optische Kameras haben wir 1000 mal 1000 oder 2000 mal 2000 oder im Weltall 4000 mal 4000 Pixel. Da kann ich halt große Fläche am Himmel gleichzeitig abmessen. Wenn ich nur einen Pixel habe, muss ich halt 4000 mal 4000 mal, da bin ich ewig mit beschäftigt, wenn ich dann das gleiche Bild abrastern würde.
Okay, ich hab jetzt nur nachgefragt, weil mir nicht so ganz klar, wie jetzt diese Bündelung ist. Also nochmal, das Licht trifft ein, trifft auf diesen großen Spiegel. Der bündelt das im Wesentlichen alles in die Mitte.
Weil dieser Spiegel gekrümmt ist, wie so eine Schüssel.
Wenn das jetzt nur Sonnenlicht wäre, dann könnte man da oben seine Schüssel Wasser drauf machen und die kochen.
Also im Moment gibt es noch die Anforderung, dass das SOFIA Flugzeug, wenn es mist und mit offener Tür mist, vor Sonnenaufgang landen muss. Es könnte sein, dass die Tür nicht zugeht. Und dann könnte, wenn der Pilot irgendwelche Manöver fliegen muss, Sonnenlicht auf den Spiegel fallen. Dann haben sie genau den Effekt, dass sie einen Brennstrahl haben, wie bei einer Lupe. Und da Schäden anrichten.
Und der würde ja mitten ins Instrument hineinballern?
Irgendwo hin. Wenn die Sonne schief rein scheint, könnte es sein, dass der Brennpunkt auf der Innenhaut liegt und dann noch einen brennt. Oder auf einer Aluminiumstruktur, die erhitzt. Und dann fällt das Ganze auseinander.
Das ist eine reale Gefahr.
Die Gefahr ist da. Erst wenn man nach vielen Flügen die Sicherheit hat, dass die Tür wirklich immer zugeht, dann wird man auch bei so einem Licht landen dürfen. Im Moment ist das noch tabu.
Das habe ich auch noch nicht so deutlich geworden. Aber es ist ja eigentlich auch klar, das Ding fliegt nur nachts.
Das fliegt nur nachts. Und zwar im Moment nachts in Amerika. Das heißt, es fliegt gerade heute.
In diesem Moment, wo wir hier gerade aufnehmen.
Und wird in einer halben Stunde landen. Das ist der Vorteil, wenn man hier in Deutschland sitzt, kann man das tagsüber verfolgen. In den USA hauen sich die Nächte um die Ohren.
Okay, aber nochmal zu den Spiegeln. Der große Spiegel fokussiert das alles auf einen zweiten Spiegel, der da drüber ist. Der wirft das dann wiederum in die Mitte des großen Spiegels zurück. Da wird es einfach abgelenkt um 90 Grad. Dann trifft es in diesen Kanal. Dieser Kanal ist das, was durch dieses Druckshot hindurchgeht durch diese Trennwand. Damit ist es dann aus dem Teleskop heraus in den Instrumentenbereich, wo auch das Team sitzt. So läuft das.
Der vordere Teil in der Kabine, wo das dann rein ist, gehört noch zum Teleskop dazu.
Aber das Instrument, was dann quasi angeflanscht wird, ragt da so rein und das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch so überhaupt die Befestigung für alles.
Im Prinzip würde es reichen, wenn man nur den Hauptspiegel hat, der fokussiert das auf einen Punkt. Aber dieser Punkt läge dann oberhalb dieses Spiegels irgendwo vielleicht sogar außerhalb vom Flugzeug, jedenfalls in dem Bereich, wo eben die Umgebungsbedingung ist. Und da kann ich kein Instrument annehmen. Also der Grund, warum ich die zwei zusätzlichen Spiegel habe, ist quasi nur, diesen Rennpunkt in die Kabine reinzulegen. Der zweite Spiegel, der obere, der hat noch die zusätzliche Eigenschaft, dass er hin und her schwingen kann, wubbeln, choppen. Damit kann ich Folgendes erreichen. Wenn ich den ein wenig bewege, dann schaue ich mal am Himmel auf die Quelle, die ich habe. Und wenn ich jetzt den Spiegel ein wenig bewege, schaue ich genau neben die Quelle. Das heißt, wenn ich Infrarot-Messverfahren habe, habe ich oft, dass ich noch Hintergrundstrahlung habe. Es ist so, als wenn Sie eine Kerze beobachten wollen direkt, und die halten die vor die Sonne. Dann werden Sie die Kerze im hellen Sonnenlicht gar nicht sehen. Wenn Sie aber die Kerze mit der Sonne beobachten und dann im nächsten Schritt die Sonne ohne die Kerze und machen das tausendmal und bilden dann immer die Differenz, dann haben Sie irgendwann dieses kleine Delta von der Kerze, das kommt dann aus dem Hintergrund raus. Das haben Sie auch im Weltall oft, in diesen Molekülwolken, ist Hintergrundstrahlung. Das heißt, Sie schauen auf Ihre Molekülwolke oder auf Ihren Stern und schauen dann auf ein Gebiet am Himmel, wo nichts ist und bilden die Differenz und machen das oft genug. Und dann kommt nur das Signal von der Quelle dann zum Schluss, bleibt übrig. Und deswegen ist dieser zweite Spiegel, kann hin und her schwingen, ein klein wenig, um das zu machen. Und zusätzlich ist der Mechanismus da, um den Fokus nachzufahren, zu zentrieren und auch die Ausrichtbenauchigkeit des Teleskops zu erhöhen. Also mit dem kann man so noch eine Feinjustage der ganzen Optik machen. Deswegen ist er dort beweglich.
Aber trotzdem, die Verbündlung über den zweiten Spiegel und das Umlenken über den dritten Spiegel bleibt dann vorne im Instrumentenbereich die potenzielle Zweitdimensionalität des Erfassenbildes, die bleibt erhalten. Das war nämlich jetzt meine ursprüngliche Frage.
Es wird halt nur fokussiert. Ja, und je größer mein Spiegel ist, umso mehr ich verhalte, umso kleiner wird das Gebiet am Himmel, was ich sehe. Umso kleinere Abstände kann ich auch trennen. Das heißt, das sogenannte Auflösungsvermögen, also die Möglichkeit, zwei Objekte noch als getrennte Objekte wahrzunehmen, wächst linear mit dem Durchmesser des Hauptspiegels. Also wenn mein Hauptspiegel dreimal so groß ist bei SOFIA im Vergleich zum KAO, kann ich Objekte am Himmel noch trennen, die dreimal enger beieinander stehen. Das heißt, ich kriege eine bessere Auflösung. Ich habe quasi ein Fernglas, das hoch auflöst. So, und dieser ganze Teil, das Prinzip dieser Tragestruktur in diesem Cavity-Bereich, Teleskop, Raum, wir haben kein vernünftiges Wort für Cavity in diesem Bereich, in dieser Höhlung. Wenn ich jetzt Bomberpilot wäre, würde ich Bomben-Schacht sagen, aber das passt irgendwie nicht. Teleskop-Schacht hört sich auch merkwürdig an. Wir verwenden oft dieses amerikanische Wort Cavity, Höhle. Also Höhle ist natürlich auch ein bisschen komisch. Diese Tragestruktur da drin dient eigentlich nur dazu, diese drei Spiegelchen sehr sauber und sehr stabil miteinander zu verbinden, dass die nicht wackeln. Und das Ganze ist dann an diesem Handelrohr befestigt und führt dann auf der anderen Seite in die Kabine. Eine der Herausforderungen war, diesen Spiegel so leicht zu gewichten, dass er möglichst leicht wird, aber nicht in sich instabil wird. Dazu muss man noch sagen, dass alle drei Spiegel eine dünne Aluminiumschicht bekommen, denn das Glas selber reflektiert, diese Glaskeramik reflektiert. Das liegt nur sehr schlecht, während eine dünne Aluminiumschicht, die wird aufgedampft in einem großen Container, wird ein hundertstel Millimeter Aluminium aufgedampft und das reflektiert dann das Licht. Das haben sie ja, wenn sie im Bad vor ihrem Spiegel stehen, ist die Aluminiumschicht hinter dem Glas und hier ist sie oben ausgemacht. Was ja auch sein muss, weil sonst das Glas ja selbst schon wieder Fremdung reinbringen würde. Das reine Cerro Dua, ohne diese Aluminiumschicht reflektiert, glaube ich nur 4% des Lichts. Der Rest geht einfach durch.
Aber wäre jetzt das Aluminium hinter dem Cerro Dua, dann würde es wahrscheinlich auch verfälschen oder absorbieren.
Wie will man es hinten anbringen, da sind diese Taschen reingefräst und wenn man es vorne aufbringt, kann man es auch säubern. Mit CO2 säubern oder man kann es auch später mit Wasser säubern. Wenn es eichverschmutzt ist, wird diese Aluminiumschicht wieder abgeätzt und wird neu bedampft. Das berechtigt man alle ein bis zwei bis drei Jahre, muss man diese Schicht erneuern.
Wenn man jetzt so einen Flug startet, wie groß ist das Team? Wie viele Leute sind da so mit dabei?
Also für einen Standardflug, die Mini-Markro, sind etwa 20 bis 25 Wissenschaftler, Ingenieure, Piloten. Die 747 hat noch ein altes Cockpit mit Analog-Anzeigen und soll zwar modernisiert werden in Zukunft, sodass ich da nicht mit zwei Piloten auskomme, sondern drei habe. Jetzt am Anfang ist noch speziell ein Navigator zusätzlich mit an Bord, um hier den geplanten Flug. Ja, wenn man den Flugweg exakt abfliegen zu können, dann hat man quasi Flugbegleiterinnen oder Flugbegleiter, sind auch notwendig für acht Mann, acht Personen in der Kabine. Brauche ich einen, der die Tür aufmachen kann im Notfall. Also die Flugbegleiter hier sind nicht dazu da, Kaffee zu reichen. Den gibt es auf SOFIA noch nicht. Aber im Notfall eben die Türen zu öffnen. Zwar hat jeder auch, kriegt eine Einweisung, wie er das im Zweifelsfall selber machen kann. Aber das ist im Moment die Vorschrift bei NASA. Und diese beiden, die dann mitfliegen, die haben natürlich noch andere Aufgaben. Und das ist klar, dass man nur als Flugleiter, das würde nicht ausfüllen. Also das sind Ingenieure, die auch im technischen Bereich arbeiten. Ja, also man hat eine Flight Crew, die das Flugzeug fliegen, drei bis fünf Leute. Oft ist auch noch ein, zwei dabei, die dort gleichzeitig eine Einweisung bekommen, sodass man das Team, was das SOFIA schult, weiter schulen kann. Also im Prinzip ist diese 7-für-7 zu fliegen, wie jeder andere alte 7-für-7, sag ich mal auch. Das heißt, die Piloten, die die Lizenz haben, eine 7-für-7 zu fliegen, dürfen SOFIA nach einer kurzen Einweisung fliegen. Die müssen halt die Besonderheiten kennen, dass hinten eine Tür ist, die auf und zu geht, und insbesondere, dass sie möglichst ruhig fliegen sollen und all diese Dinge. Aber im Prinzip braucht das da nicht eine jahrelange Ausbildung. Das heißt, wenn ein normaler 7-für-7 fliegen darf, darf nach einer kurzen Einweisung zwei, drei Flüge oder so mit fliegen, darf auch SOFIA fliegen. Ja, dann hat man im Kabinenbereich einen Mission-Direktor. Also es ist immer jemand da, der für den Wissenschaftsbereich die Gesamtverantwortung hat, der also für das Instrument, fürs Teleskop sozusagen alles koordiniert. Das sind ein bis zwei Mitarbeiter. Dann, um das Teleskop zu betreiben, hat man zurzeit zwei Teleskop-Operateure an Bord und für diesen Sekundär-Spiegel, der diese Schwingungen auch ausführen kann, noch speziell einen mit an Bord, weil das ein hochsensibles Gerät ist, was im Moment noch der Betreuung bedarf. Dann fliegen in der Regel noch ein, zwei Ingenieure vom Teleskop-Team mit, um das Teleskop weiter auszutesten, weil wir sind sozusagen in einer gemischten Test- und Betriebsphase, also so eine Übergangsphase, wo noch nicht alles optimal funktioniert. Man möchte aber nicht jetzt drei Jahre lang testen und die Wissenschaftler warten lassen, sondern man macht immer einen alternierenden Betrieb mit Testflügen, mit Wissenschaftsflügen, wobei die Wissenschaftsflüge eben auch für Testmessungen verwendet werden. Deswegen sind mehr Ingenieure mit an Bord als für den Routinebetrieb eigentlich notwendig.
Also es ist absehbar, dass später noch ein paar von diesen Positionen wegfallen?
Das können ein, zwei, müssen nicht immer mitfliegen. Vieles läuft natürlich automatisch ab, aber gerade jetzt, wo die Instrumente das erste Mal eingesetzt werden, fliegt man eben für jedes Subsystem einen Spezialisten mit, damit er im Zweifelsfall im Flug auch noch Fehler beheben kann. Also wenn was ausfällt, das ist eben auch einer der Vorteile eines Flugzeuggetragenen-Observatores, vielleicht einem Stiliten. Hier können Sie hands-on, wenn das Teleskop arretiert ist, gebremst ist, am System arbeiten.
Ohne Astronautenausbildung?
Ohne Astronautenausbildung. Das geht also über das Rebooten eines Laptops hinaus. Man kann also noch Parameter setzen, man kann flüssig Helium nachfüllen, falls notwendig, und solche Dinge. Das ist natürlich eingeschränkt. Man hat natürlich nicht, Gott weiß was, jetzt für Geräte mit an Bord. Oft sind die Fehler so, dass sie sich auch nicht, wenn es ernsthafte Fehler sind, direkt im Flug beheben lassen. Aber wenn es zu Kleinigkeiten sind, wie einfach mal draufhauen, was ja oft hilft, erstaunlicherweise auch heute noch, und der Wissenschaftler sieht eben direkt auf seinem Monitor, was kommt an Daten rein? Kommt überhaupt was? Bin ich wirklich auf dem Punkt, den ich haben wollte, oder bin ich haarscharf daneben, da sagt der Teleskop-Operator, ich bin genau am Ziel. Der Wissenschaftler sagt, ich sehe aber nichts. Das heißt, Instrument und Teleskop sind ein bisschen misseligned, nicht genau auseinander ausgerichtet. Das kann man bei Bodentests nicht so hundertprozentig rauskriegen. Also dann kann man dann nachjustieren. Also das ist schon sehr hilfreich, wenn die Wissenschaftler mit ihrem Instrument an Bord sind.
Der Start ist dann natürlich mit geschlossener Luke, nehme ich mal an, und dann fliegt man eine Weile. Wenn man sich sicher ist, jetzt kann man auch mal anfangen. Dann geht diese Luke auf. Wie lange braucht die? Geht das so, ist sie da, oder ist das so ein längerer Prozess?
Also man braucht etwa eine gute halbe Stunde, um von Null auf diese 37.000 Fuß zu kommen. Das ist das Minimum, wo man die Tür aufmachen möchte, weil drunter ist zu viel Wasserdampf, da lohnt es sich nicht.
Und das wird ja auch wahrscheinlich das Teleskop selbst auch?
Nein, das Teleskop, also diese Restturbulenzen, die ich erwähnt hatte, sind umso geringer, je höher man ist. Es kann ja sein, dass wenn man aus 45.000 Fuß nach erfolgreicher Messung wieder landen möchte, geht plötzlich die Tür nicht zu. Und ich habe 20 bis 40 Leute an Bord. Ich muss also sicherstellen, dass der Flieger auch mit offener Tür landen kann. Und das hat man vorweg alles getestet. Also man hat die Tür erstmal geschlossen gehabt und hat jede Menge Testflüge noch gemacht und dann hat man in einer bestimmten Höhe, 20.000 Fuß, ganz vorsichtig die Tür aufgemacht, so ein kleines bisschen, bis eine halbe Stunde geflogen. Dann hat man sie weiter aufgemacht und hat sich peu à peu daran getastet. Man hat den Schwenkbereich, den Elevationsbereich peu à peu erhöht. Man hat dann 20, 25, 30, 30, wo man rausguckt, wo man rausschaut und hat so diesen ganzen Parameterbereich, also Höhe, Geschwindigkeit, Tür auf, Tür zu, durchgeflogen. Es waren ungefähr 40 Testflüge insgesamt mit verschiedenen Höhenstaffelungen, Geschwindigkeiten. Sodass man sich sicher war, dass das Werkzeug in jeder Situation Tür auf, Tür zu, Tür ganz auf, Tür ein bisschen auf, Tür hoch, Tür niedrig, wo Geschwindigkeit in den Geschwindigkeiten fliegen kann, ohne dass es Stabilitätsprobleme gibt und auch strukturelle Probleme. Wenn die Schwingungen zu groß werden, kann ein Flugzeug auseinanderbrechen, wenn es zu stark wird. Das ist alles sichergestellt worden, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Das muss alles verifiziert werden. Die Computersimulationen sind sehr gut heutzutage, aber auch moderne Flugzeuge wie Boeing oder Airbus, man nimmt ein Flugzeug hin und schwingt es kaputt, solange bis es bricht. Ein ganzes Flugzeug. Man will sich sicher sehen, wo ist wirklich die Grenze, auch die Ermüdungsgrenze. Sie können es dreimal schwingen, aber nichts passiert. Wenn Sie das tausendmal machen, haben Sie diesen sogenannten Ermüdungsbruch. Das Material wird spröde und es ist durch. Wenn man ein Draht durchbiegen will, dann macht man das oft genug und irgendwann ist es auch kaputt. Ja, also das, gut, man fliegt also bis auf 37.000 Fuß circa und sieht zu, dass dann gerade die Sonne untergegangen ist. Das passt man so an, dass das genau hinkommt. Dann öffnet man die Tür und es gibt ein Türsystem, wenn man genau so ist, mit zwei Türen. Es gibt eine obere, stabile Tür und eine untere, flexible Tür. Die obere, stabile, muss man sich vorstellen wie bei diesen größeren Müllcontainern, wo man diese Tür so, den Deckel so, an diesen zwei Griffen so hochschiebt. So bewegt sich diese Tür natürlich nicht mit Griffen, sondern mit Getriebe, geht diese Tür auf, bis die Türöffnung so groß ist, dass das Teleskop ungestört durchschauen kann. Wenn sich jetzt und das Teleskop schaut, dann knapp über dem Horizont bei 20 Grad Elevation, heißt dieser Begriff. Und wenn jetzt das Teleskop kann, bis auf 60 Grad hochschwenken, weil sonst hätte man immer nur einen kleinen Bereich am Himmel, den man sehen kann. Man möchte halt möglichst viel sehen können. Und wenn das Teleskop von diesen 20 Grad auf 50 Grad hochschwenkt, muss natürlich diese Tür, diese Ausrottür, sich mitbewegen nach oben. Sie muss weiter aufgehen. Es wird aber gleichzeitig unten ein Loch entstehen. Und dann zieht diese obere Tür, eine untere Tür, mit hoch, sodass diese Öffnung immer die minimale Größe ist.
Also so Oberlippe, Unterlippe.
Ja, exakt. Und diese Unterlippe, die besteht aus einer Art Rolladentür. Das sind so Rolladenelemente von dieser von etwa 40 Zentimeter Breite und eben 4 Meter lang. Und die ist flexible, deswegen nennt man sie sich flexible lower door. Und die dient nur dazu, diese Luftströmung in diesem Teleskopschacht minimal zu halten. Je kleiner die Öffnung ist, umso weniger verwirbelt es sich. Und während die obere Tür dann ganz zufährt, verschwindet die untere im unteren Teil des Flugzeugs innen drin. Sie hat also keine Dichtungseigenschaft. Und während die obere Tür schließt dann nachher dicht ab, sodass auch kein Staub, kein Regen, nichts reinkommen kann. Und deswegen ist sie auch starr und schließt dicht ab. Die untere nennt sich flexibel. Sie soll nur die Luftströmung ein bisschen einschränken. Man macht das also. In dieser Höhe wird die Tür geöffnet. Das Teleskop wird in die Position gebracht, in die das erste Objekt zu beobachten ist. Das Flugzeug fliegt genau in die Richtung, dass man im rechten Winkel rausschauen kann. In der Azimut-Ebene kann ich das Teleskop kaum bewegen, nur wenige Grad, weil sonst schaue ich ja vor diesen Rumpf.
Was ist die Azimut-Ebene?
Azimut ist das, was ich auf der Ebene drehe, von 0 bis 360 Grad, also wie ein Kompassnadel. Die Scheibe. Genau, mein Teleskop schaut aus diesem Schacht, der ist zeitlich begrenzt. Ich kann nicht das Teleskop um plus, minus 20 Grad in der Ebene drehen, sondern da kann ich das ganze Flugzeug drehen. Ich muss also den Piloten sagen, wenn ich den Polarstern sehen will, muss er exakt nach Osten fliegen, weil das Teleskop links rausschaut. Und wenn ich ein Objekt exakt im Osten beobachten will, muss der Pilot exakt nach Süden fliegen.
Aber wäre es nicht eigentlich von meinem Verständnis her sinnvoller, wenn das Gerät einfach nach oben rausguckt und nicht nach links?
Ja, wenn es nur nach oben rausschaut, dann sehen sie aber nur die Objekte, die oben sind und können nicht sozusagen von Horizont bis oben alles abfahren.
Ja, wie weit bis nach oben kann er denn?
Er kann von 20 bis 60 Grad.
Und das reicht aus?
Das reicht aus. Wenn ein Objekt bei 70 Grad steht, muss ich eben ein halbes Jahr warten, bis es am Himmel in einer anderen Position ist. Man steht so tief, mal stehen sie hoch.
Okay, aber das, was sozusagen zu hoch steht, das kann das Teleskop nicht sehen. Aber dann wartet man einfach, bis die Erde sich entsprechend gedreht hat.
Oder das Teleskop, das Flugzeug müsste eine Rolle sozusagen fliegen.
Ja, das war jetzt mal eine Frage, ob wir solche Ausgleichmaßnahmen machen.
Das kann es natürlich nicht stabil machen. Das kann es nur für ein paar Sekunden, dann schwenkt es ja weg.
Das bringt natürlich nichts.
Es wird immer versucht, das Flugzeug möglichst gerade zu halten.
Oder man fliegt woanders.
Ja, und das ist der Grund, warum man eben in diesem Elevationsbereich, in diesem Schwenkbereich von oben nach unten, dass man da eben von 20 bis 60 Grad geht, damit man eine gewisse Überdeckung, einen Streifen, am Himmel hat. Wenn ich jetzt das Flugzeug, kann ich ja um 360 Grad auf meiner Erdscheibe drehen. Dann habe ich ja so einen Streifen, wo ich von 20 bis 60 Grad einen riesen Streifen am Himmel abdecken kann. Und wenn ich das von Kalifornien aus mache, habe ich in diesem Streifen andere Objekte, als wenn ich das zur gleichen Zeit von Hawaii oder Neuseeland ausmache oder von Deutschland aus. Wenn man weiter nach Süden kommt, sieht man auch andere Sternbilder plötzlich. Das ist eben, weil die Erde eine Kugel ist. Ja, also man macht, wie gesagt, diese Tür auf. Der Pilot fliegt genau in die Richtung, die man vorher festgelegt hat. Der Flugplan wird vorher genau festgelegt. Und dann wird das Instrument in Betrieb genommen. Alle Teleskopsysteme, das heißt, das Teleskop ist gebremst. Die Bremsen werden gelöst. Das sind echt richtige Scheibenbremsen. Und dann wird das Teleskop exakt auf die Position stabilisiert, die der Astronom haben möchte. Nun hatten wir schon gesagt, das Flugzeug wackelt und dreht sich und bewegt sich leicht ein bisschen. Und das Teleskop ist davon reibungsmäßig entkoppelt. Aber es muss trotzdem über Motoren auf diesen Punkt genau ausgerichtet werden, den der Astronom beobachten will. Und dazu muss ich natürlich die Position des Teleskops auch genau wissen. Und messen tue ich das mit einem Kreiselsystem. Ich habe drei senkrecht zueinander stehende Glasfaserkreisel, die mir die Lage des Teleskops exakt auf 10-12 Bogen bilden. Glasfaserkreisel, es gibt ja mechanische Kreisel, das kennen Sie von diesen Spinnkreiseln oder von... Ja, ein Kreisel ist im Prinzip, wenn Sie ein Fahrrad haben und das um die Achse rotieren lassen, dann wissen Sie, das können Sie nicht einfach drehen. Das widerstrebt sich dagegen, seine Reaktion zu verändern.
Deswegen fällt das Fahrrad nicht um.
Deswegen fällt das Fahrrad nicht um. Und ein Kreisel ist eben im Raum stabil. Wenn das Flugzeug sich dreht, bleibt der Kreisel einfach in der Position, wie er steht. Oder wenn das Teleskop sich bewegt, der Kreisel guckt immer in die gleiche Richtung. Und dann messe ich die Abweichung, die das Teleskop zu diesem Kreisel hat. Glasfaser heißt nun, dass ich nicht mehr einen mechanischen Kreisel habe, sondern dass ich mehrere Kilometer Glasfaser aufgewickelt habe. Und in dieser Glasfaser einen Laserstrahl einmal von vorne nach hinten und einmal von hinten nach vorne laufen lasse. Und wenn ich jetzt eine Bewegung habe, dann habe ich diesen Dopplereffekt in diesem Glasfaser, sodass ich, wenn sich die Laserphoton, die ich in zwei Richtungen durchgeschickt habe, anschließend wieder treffen, haben die eine leichte Phasenverschiebung, weil der eine gegen die Geschwindigkeit und der andere mit der Geschwindigkeit gelaufen ist.
Daran kann man dann sehen, ob sich das gedreht hat oder nicht. Das ist viel genauer.
Ja, das ist genauer und es soll nicht solchen Störungen unterworfen. Das ist keine Neuentwicklung in Sachen SOFIA.
Ja, das kannte ich noch nicht, aber es trotzdem ist.
Was ich da mache, ist, so einen Laserstrahl kann man sich ja als Lichtwelle vorstellen. Wenn ich den in der einen Richtung laufen lasse, also ich spalte den Laserstrahl auf, der eine Hälfte läuft in die eine Richtung, die andere läuft die andere Richtung, die fünf Kilometer in die andere Richtung. Und wenn ich jetzt keine Bewegung habe und sie treffen sich wieder, müssten Wellen, Täler und Wellenberge exakt immer noch übereinander liegen. Wenn ich jetzt aber eine Bewegung habe, die senkrecht zu dieser Richtung ist, dann haben sich die Wellen, Täler und Wellenberge von dem links und dem rechts laufenden leicht verschoben. Die liegen also nicht übereinander. Und das kann ich messen. Wenn ich sehe, das ist eine halbe Wellenlänge, weiß ich, ich habe so und so viel relativ Geschwindigkeit gehabt und das gerechne ich um in eine Drehbewegung etc.
Und das fließt dann alles in diese Echtzeitsteuerung, die Teleskoplagerung mit an?
Ja, und damit ist das Teleskop wirklich weltaustabil. Das ist inertial stabilisiert quasi gegen das Weltall. Es sind ja keine Störungen da. Es ist nicht von der Erdrotation, von der Bewegung der Erde um die Sonne, nichts abhängig.
Und die eigentliche Fixierung aber auf das Weltall, die geht dann über die Beobachtung der Sterne?
Ja, das ist so, selbst die besten Kreisel, auch Glasfaserkreisel, haben einen technischen Nachteil, dass sie einen gewissen Drift haben, nennt man das. Das heißt, auch wenn ich keine Bewegungen habe, wandern die langsam weg. Das ist zwar ganz langsam, aber würde mich stören. Und deswegen mache ich zusätzlich, sind am Teleskop, in der Teleskopschacht zwei Nachführkameras angebracht, die mir ein Bild der Sterne am Himmel liefern. Und dann mache ich immer ein Update, alle paar Sekunden habe ich ein neues Bild. Und dann sehe ich, dass in meinem Zielfernrohr der Stern, auf den ich ein Gott sei Dank leicht weggewandert ist, weil die Kreisel eben nicht 100% bei Null stehen bleiben, sondern leicht wegdriften. Und dann sage ich, okay, der ist eine Bogensekunde weggefahren, ich gebe dem Kreisel die Information, dass er eine Bogensekunde weggewandert ist, und dann korrigiert er das. Und wenn sie das fünf Minuten machen, diese Drift ist relativ linear, dann können sie die auch vorhersagen, wie er sich gleich daneben benimmt. Das wird dann sozusagen eine Kontrollschleife.
Also er korrigiert sich sozusagen schon, bevor er es eigentlich machen muss.
Das heißt, sie haben der Kreisel selber stabilisiert, aber er hat eine Kontrollschleife, die den Kreisel wieder kontrolliert, ob er keinen Unfug macht, um es mal so auszudrücken.
Und dadurch erreicht man einfach diese exakte Ausrichtung auf das All und genau den Punkt, den man jetzt auch wirklich mal messen möchte.
Dadurch erreiche ich als erstes mal die genaue Information, wo bin ich überhaupt. Und dann muss ich über die schon beschriebenen elektromagnetischen Antriebe, das Teleskop, dann auch genau in diese Position rücken. Und das ist dem Teleskop ziemlich egal, was das Flugzeug zwischenzeitlich macht, solange es in dem Bereich bleibt, in dem Schwenkbereich, den das Teleskop anblicken kann. Also wenn man mitfliegt und steht dann ein paar Meter vor dem Instrument, dann sieht man oder glaubt zu sehen, wie das während des Flugs das Teleskop rumwackelt, sich leicht bewegt. Aber das Teleskop bewegt sich nicht die Bohne, sondern es ist das Flugzeug, das sich ins Teleskop rum bewegt.
Das heißt, da kann man das erste Mal sehen, wie sich das Flugzeug tatsächlich bewegt.
Ja, das Teleskop steht Rock Stable.
Gibt es davon ein Video im Netz?
Ja, müsste es geben. Das ist von einem der Ingenieure aufgenommen mit seinem Handy. Er hat einfach eine Sequenz aufgenommen, als es hier so ein bisschen turbulent wurde und alle sich hinsetzen mussten. Man sieht, man will das Teleskop rumschocken, aber man weiß genau, wer wusste, dass es noch arbeitet.
Ist das im Netz? Dann werden wir darauf linken.
Es ist noch nicht im Netz, weil uns die Frage war, ob das schon veröffentlicht werden darf. Ich muss da mal nachhaken, ob man sowas... Das kommt garantiert irgendwann, weil das ist nichts Geheimnisvolles.
Wenn es da ist, linken wir dann darauf. Mal gucken, ob das nicht uns Zeitpunkt dieses Podcasts schon soweit ist oder ob wir es nachreichen müssen. Ja, jetzt sind wir noch in der Luft.
Man fliegt dann vielleicht eine halbe Stunde, um ein bestimmtes Objekt zu sehen. Das hängt davon ab, wie viele Tonnen ich sammeln muss in meinem Detektor, um ein vernünftiges Signal zu bekommen, was nicht im Rauschen untergeht. In der Zeit wandert natürlich der Stern am Himmel oder die Erde dreht sich. Das Ding wandert am Himmel und der Pilot muss also sein Flugzeug nachführen. Er muss also eine ganz leichte Kurve fliegen, je nachdem, in welche Richtung er gerade fliegt. Wenn er das beendet hat, wenn der Wissenschaftler sagt, die halbe Stunde wollte ich in diese Richtung fliegen, jetzt will ich ein Objekt beobachten, was 90 Grad verdreht ist, dann wird das Teleskop kurz gebremst, festgehalten, und der Pilot fliegt eine 90-Grad-Kurve, stabilisiert das Ganze wieder und steuert die neue Richtung an. Dann geht die nächste Sequenz los. So ein Flug besteht aus verschiedenen Streckenabschnitten, wo ich bestimmte Objekte beobachte.
Und alles muss exakt geführt werden?
Alles wird exakt vorher ausgerechnet. Selbst unter Berücksichtigung der Winde, die man erwartet. Der Pilot kann ja nicht, um den Wind zu kompensieren, das Flugzeug leicht drehen. Dann ist das Objekt weg. Er muss immer auf das Objekt schauen, in eine bestimmte Richtung fliegen. Wenn der Wind ihn wegtreibt, dann landet er nicht an dem Punkt, wo er drehen möchte, sondern ist versetzt dazu. Das heißt, das muss man online im Flug korrigieren können, sodass man die nächste Beobachtungsstrecke immer noch die ist, die man haben wollte. Das heißt, es gibt dann so ein Zick-Zack-Muster. Und da kommt ja noch hinzu, dass man in der Regel wieder da landen möchte, wo man gestartet ist. Wenn jetzt ein Wissenschaftler, also das Flugzeug hat eine Flugzeit von zehn Stunden, sagt auf und ab, stich abgerechnet, vielleicht acht Stunden mögliche Messzeit. Wenn er acht Stunden in eine Richtung schauen möchte, dann geht das ja nicht. Er kann nur vier Stunden in eine Richtung, da muss er vier Stunden zurückfliegen. Das heißt, er muss sich überlegen, dass er am Rückflug andere Objekte in sein Gesicht fällt, oder er muss ein Dreieck fliegen oder ein Vieleck. Also das ist ein, je nachdem, was er beobachten will, gibt das einen ziemlich, ja, winkligen, eckigen Flug. Und die Messflüge bisher waren alle über dem amerikanischen Kontinent. Und auch der heutige Flug ging, ich gerade ging von Kalifornien aus bis oben zur kanadischen Grenze nach Washington. Also fast über Boeing und dann in südöstlicher Richtung runter bis Texas und dann von Texas zurück nach Kalifornien. Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist das Ding gerade gelandet. Also das war der erste Flug in dieser Basic Science Sequenz mit dem amerikanischen Vorkass-Instrument. Also während wir hier gerade reden und es hier heller Tag ist, flog man dort durch die Nacht.
Für den Piloten ist das so ein bisschen das Äquivalent zum Dressurreiten. Da muss man ja auch so ein bisschen extrem. Jetzt hier den Pivot mal schön das Pferd drehen und so. Man hat dieses schwere Gerät, was gerne ein bisschen zucken wollen würde, aber darf nicht. Beziehungsweise darf ein bisschen zucken, aber eben nicht zu viel.
Ja und typischerweise so ein Messflug, wo dann vielleicht zwei bis zehn Objekte beobachtet werden, je nachdem, wie lange ich brauche. Aus diesen einzelnen Beobachtungsstrecken, sogenannten LEX, sich Beinchen zusammensetzt. Und wenn die Art schon rum sind, ja dann hilft alles nichts, dann muss alles abgeschaltet werden. Das Teleskop wird wieder arretiert, die Tür geht zu und man landet. Man braucht dann eine halbe Stunde, also das geht dann sehr schnell, nicht, wenn man so hier in der Verkehrsmaschine über Atlantik fliegt, dann weiß ich schon, irgendwo ab England fängt man langsam mit dem Sinkflug an und braucht eine gute Stunde, bis man unten ist. Also hier wird bis zur letzten Sekunde, die möglich ist, gemessen und dann geht es so schnell wie möglich runter. Ja, Tür auf und zu, hatten sie gefragt.
Tür macht man dann aber dann, bevor es runtergeht, die Tür dann wieder zu?
Ja, wenn man nicht mehr misst, macht man die Tür zu. Und um die Tür auf und zu zu machen, das sind zehn Sekunden auf und zu, also das geht relativ schnell.
Ich frage mich jetzt, ich meine, da oben ist es ja dann ziemlich kalt, darauf muss ja klar das Teleskop sowieso darauf ausgelegt sein bzw. profitiert ja dann auch von dieser Kälte, aber ist diese Temperaturdifferenz dann so, gerade bei so einem schnellen Landen, ist das ein Problem?
Ja, das ist, sowohl beim Start als auch bei der Endung hat man im Prinzip ein Temperaturproblem. Wenn man losfliegt, gerade wenn man in der kalifornischen Wüste im Nachmittag in der Sonne gestanden hat, ist es da leicht 40 Grad oder sowas plus und dann ist man in einer halben Stunde, in dreiviertel Stunde auf 10 Kilometer Höhe, da ist es minus 40 Grad. Und das würde natürlich bedeuten, dass sich die ganze Optik verzieht, obwohl es ein thermostabiler Spiegel ist, aber die Tragessprung, alles, man wäre total aus dem Fokus raus und würde unscharf sehen. Und deswegen war es immer beabsicht, dass man das am Boden vorkühlt. Also am Boden ist die Tür zu, die ganze Teleskopschacht ist abgedichtet und man kühlt das am Boden auf minus 40 Grad vor. Und dann fliegt man hoch, öffnet die Tür und hat ein Temperatur-Gleichgewicht. Das ist im Moment noch nicht implementiert, das wird in den nächsten Monaten passieren. Da ist man ein bisschen hinter dem Zeitplan her, dass man das macht.
Wie kühlt man denn das ab?
So dass man jetzt schon in 15.000 Fuß Höhe die Tür aufmacht und in dem etwas langsamer aufsteigt und dabei kühlt sich das gleichmäßig ab. Wenn man dann nach einer dreiviertel Stunde mit der Messung beginnt, ist man noch nicht im Gleichgewicht. Das heißt, das ist noch im Moment ein Nachteil, der sich auch auf die Qualität der Messung negativ auswirkt. Also das wird spätestens im nächsten Sommer broben sein.
Wie kühlt man das ab?
Wenn man auf die Höhe fliegt, macht man das einfach so, dass man die Tür aufmacht und dann kühlt es sich einfach so, wie sieht es aus, das Fenster auf dem Handel.
Ich meine, es soll schon vorher gekühlt werden.
Ja, da wird man mit flüssig Stickstoff den flüssigen Stickstoff verdampfen und als kaltes Gas durchspülen sozusagen. Da sind Ohrsysteme verlegt und Pumpe und dann spült man einfach wie ein Kühlschrank.
Der fliegende Kühlschrank, SOFIA, mit Spiegel.
Bei der Landung hat man das umgekehrte Problem, wenn man die Tür auflassen würde und kommt mit einem minus 40 Grad kalten Spiegel in die 40 Grad oder 20 Grad heiße Wüste und es ist noch ein bisschen feucht, da hätte man sofort Eis auf dem Spiegel. Das darf auf gar keinen Fall sein. Deswegen auch sofort die Tür zu machen und dann wird die Luft, die dort zirkuliert, noch von einem System getrocknet. Das ist wie bei einem Wäschetrockner. Da gibt es ja so Systeme, die das Wasser rausziehen und dann haben sie trockene Luft und da kann ja kein Eis.
Okay, aber das heißt, wenn jetzt wirklich mal dieser Fall eintreffen würde, dass das Schott nicht schließt, die Tür nicht schließt, dann könnte es sein, dass sich Eis bildet am Spiegel. Das heißt, man müsste dann sehr langsam runterfliegen, da kann man einfach nichts machen.
Kann man aber nicht mehr. Man hat ja nur begrenzt Treibstoff noch an Bord. Man hat Eis am Spiegel und dann muss man schauen, ob man anschließend den Spiegel waschen muss. Das sehen Sie auch beim Auto, wenn Sie nachts draußen stehen haben, Sie hatten einen Bodenfrost und Sie haben eine Eisschicht drauf, die Sonne taut das Eis weg. Irgendwann ist es weg, aber Sie sehen trotzdem diese schlieren Wasserflecken. Das wäre auf dem Spiegel auch, und dann müsste man den anschließend säubern. Das geht, das hat man schon gemacht. Wenn es ganz schlimm kommt, muss man diese Aluminiumschicht wieder abätzen und den Spiegel neu bedampfen, neu beschichten. Dazu muss man ihn rausnehmen, und das ist eine Woche Aufwand. Das möchte man natürlich vermeiden.
Ja, das war ja jetzt eine ausführliche Reise, ich glaube. Jetzt haben wir hier aber auch das Wichtigste zusammengetragen. Aber, wenn uns noch weiter interessiert, es gibt natürlich auch eine Webseite zu dem Projekt, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, es gibt mehrere Webseiten, also ich habe glaube ich noch nicht erwähnt, dass wir den Beitrag, den wir den USA liefern, nicht hier vom DLR selber mit Personal ausstatten, sondern dass wir hier in Deutschland das im Auftrag vergeben. Das ist auch im Wettbewerb vergeben worden. Wir haben ja ein Institut gründen lassen, das Deutsche SOFIA-Institut, was an der Universität Stuttgart angesiedelt ist. Die Universität Stuttgart hat von uns einen Vertrag mit der Universität Stuttgart, die beschreibt, was dort gemacht werden muss. Die Universität Stuttgart entsendet zum Beispiel 15 bis 20 Mitarbeiter in die USA an den Standort des Flugzeugs, die dort die Wartungsarbeiten, das Teleskop betreiben, Verbesserungsmaßnahmen durchführen und all diese Dinge, die notwendig sind. Ersatzteilbeschaffung, all diese Aufgaben werden von diesem deutschen SOFIA-Institut DSI an der Uni Stuttgart gemacht. Und die haben auch ihre eigene Website, wo diese Dinge beschrieben werden, neben der DLR-Website. Die NASA hat natürlich ihre Website, wo sie mehr auf die NASA-Schwerpunkte, die NASA-Aktivitäten abhebt. Ein wichtiger Aspekt in diesem Vertrag mit der Universität Stuttgart ist auch die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Das heißt, die Universität Stuttgart wird neben der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit des DLR auch gezielt Öffentlichkeitsarbeit in dem Sinne durch, dass sie auch Bildungsarbeit macht, dass sie Programme mit Schulen, dass sie Partnerschulen hat, die über SOFIA informiert werden, die kleine Projekte einreichen, was sie mit SOFIA machen. Das DSI hat einen sogenannten Infrarot-Koffer entworfen. Dort sind typische, einfache Experimente drin, die den Charakter von Infrarot-Strahlung nachweisen. Was wenige wissen, viele Handys haben ja eine kleine Kamera. Viele Handys haben ihre, oder hat es da jede.
Fast alle jetzt schon.
Und die sind zum Teil bis in den Infrarotbereich sensibel. Das heißt, sie können mit dem Handy Wärmestrahlung aufnehmen, wenn sie wissen, wie es geht. Das können wahrscheinlich nicht alle, aber es gibt einige, die das können.
Da, wenn man so eine gedrückte Fernbedienung fotografiert, dann sieht man schon da so einen Punkt.
Richtig, die arbeiten genau in diesem Infrarotbereich teilweise. Und diese Koffer werden ausgeliehen, zur Verfügung gestellt oder für Aktivitäten. Es ist geplant, dass der eine oder andere Lehrer auf SOFIA mitfliegt und dann seinen Schülern berichtet, was da los war. Wir schauen mal, ob in Zukunft hier Mitfluggelegenheiten vergeben werden für Jugendforscht-Gewinner oder ähnliche Aspekte. Was uns eigentlich langfristig vorschwebt, wir hatten gerade schon gesagt, während wir hier sitzen und zuschauen, wie SOFIA gerade geflogen ist. Also wenn SOFIA in den USA fliegt, abends um 12 Uhr, Mitternacht und Messungen macht, ist es in Deutschland 9 Uhr. 9 Stunden Differenz in der Regel zu Kalifornien. Das ist die beste Schulzeit, also wenn man live Dinge in die Schulen reinspielt, hat man da direkt die Möglichkeiten, das mitzuverfolgen. Das ist im Moment nicht möglich. Man hat im Moment auch keinen Satelink zum Pfleger. Das ist mal angedacht, wenn mal Geld genug dafür da ist und NASA Zeit hat, das einzubauen, dann wird das eventuell mal gemacht. Also da gibt es ein breites Programm.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ganze Projekt nicht nur jetzt eine neue und ja auch jetzt nicht so selbstverständliche Zusammenarbeit zwischen NASA und DLR, sondern es ist auch noch sehr in die Forschungslandschaft und in die Ausbildungslandschaft mit eingebettet.
Ja, also ich bin schon gesagt, dass das SOFIA, wenn es um die Instrumente angeht, die allerneuesten Instrumente dran hat. Es hat auch den Vorteil, dass es sehr gut für die Ausbildung von Nachwuchsforschern, in dem Fall eben zwischen der eigentlichen Fertigstellung des Instruments, der Messung und der Auswertung zum Beispiel als Doktorarbeit relativ vergleichsweise weniger Zeit vergeht, als wenn ich das Ganze auf dem Satelliten mache. Und auch die Mitarbeiter des DSI, die vor Ort in Bamdel arbeiten, sind zum Teil Mitarbeiter, die gerade von der Hochschule kommen und dort sozusagen am SOFIA Projekt ihre Ausbildung fortführen und ihre Doktorarbeiten dort aus diesen Sachen machen. Und das war mit einer der Gründe, warum wir gesagt haben, wir überweisen nicht einfach jedes Jahr 5 Millionen Euro an die NASA. Und nun seht mal zu, wie ihr da euren Betrieb mit unterstützt, sondern uns war wichtig, dass wir eben Personal aus Deutschland vor Ort haben, einmal um eben auch das Geld des deutschen Steuerzahlers für deutsche Mitarbeiter zu verwenden, aber insbesondere auch, um diese Verbindung aufrechtzuerhalten. Wenn man nur das Geld drüber schickt und dann nach drei Jahren ist das ein rein amerikanisches Observatorium.
Und so wird halt die lokale Forschungslandschaft überhaupt auch erst herum mit aufgebaut. Und man hat ja auch die eigenen Kompetenzen. Das ist natürlich jetzt auch gerade für junge Forscher dann auch durchaus mal ein Objekt, das man sich vielleicht näher anschauen sollte, wenn man ohnehin in diesem Bereich arbeitet. Ich meine, für welche Disziplinen könnte da diese Verbindung zu dem SOFIA-Projekt interessant sein? Jetzt außer den Astronomie-Selbstverständnigkeiten?
Das breite Feld der Astronomie, die Astronomie deckt ja eigentlich alle physikalischen Dinge ab. Wenn man sich spezialisiert, dann was natürlich das Teleskop angeht, sind gerade solche Dinge wie Kreisel, Lageregelung, sehr interessante, moderne Materialien wie Kohlefaser. Der Sekundärspiegel steht aus Silizium Capit, das ist ein Material, das man zum Teil für Scheibenbremsen bei Formel 1 verwendet. Das ist ein sehr hochfestes, hitzebeständiges Material. Da werden sehr viele Dinge eingesetzt. Die Kooperation mit NASA-Ingenieuren ist eine Herausforderung. Die europäische und die amerikanische Welt sind unterschiedliche Kulturen, auch was Wissenschaft, Wissenschaft vielleicht weniger, aber gerade was auch Ingenieure angeht, das Verhältnis. Da kann man also eine Menge lernen, auch wie man unterschiedlich arbeitet.
Was für Unterschiede sind das?
Ja, das sind Unterschiede. Also zum Beispiel ein deutscher Ingenieur darf auch einen Schraubendreher in die Hand nehmen, Drehmomentschlüssel und selber im Flugzeug am Teleskop schrauben. Ein amerikanischer Ingenieur wäre das undenkbar, der schreibt genau auf, was gemacht werden muss und dann macht ein Mechaniker diese Arbeit. Und der wird aber überwacht von Qualitätssicherungsleuten. Das heißt, in den USA ist die Arbeit sehr viel mehr strukturierter und hierarchiert. Es gibt sozusagen Hierarchie-Ebenen und es geht von oben nach unten. Das hat Vor- und Nachteile, kann man sich vorstellen. Das hat sicherlich Vorteile, wenn man am Fließband steht und immer bestimmte Arbeiten machen muss und eingespielt ist. Ich würde bei SOFIA den Vorteil in europäischen Rangehensweise sehen, dass ein Ingenieur eben auch selber das zusammenschraubt, was er entwickelt hat und dann sozusagen mehr ganzheitlich an die Sache rangeht. Ich bin selber kein Ingenieur, ich sehe das nur von außen und sehe da so ein bisschen die Unterschiede. Ich will damit auch nicht sagen, ob das eine besser und das andere schlechter ist.
Das ist anders halt.
Das ist einfach unterschiedlich. Und auch mal drei Jahre am Stück in den USA vor Ort zu leben, ist was anderes als ein paar Mal im Jahr für eine Woche hinzufliegen. Man lernt eine Kultur eben dann kennen, wenn man wirklich permanent vor Ort dort wohnt, amerikanische Nachbarn hat, mit denen Kontakt kommt, ist das was anderes, als wenn man immer nur auf Meetings mit Wissenschaftlern und Ingenieuren zu tun hat. Das ist eine andere Welt.
Das ist sicherlich auch ein Lerneffekt in beide Richtungen. Da kommen wieder die Deutschen, da schraubt der Ingenieur noch selbst.
Ja, das führt manchmal auch zu kleineren Reibereien. Weil die Amerikaner dann die Sorge haben, kann der das überhaupt? In den USA, der Ingenieur, sagt der Mechaniker, das kann der doch gar nicht. Um Gottes Willen, was macht der da? Der macht mir mein Gerät kaputt. Der weiß eben nicht, dass in Deutschland der Ingenieur das gelernt hat.
Ja, das ist interessant. Ich würde da gar nicht so drüber nachdenken. Für mich ist es irgendwie selbstverständlich, dass ein Ingenieur natürlich jemand ist, der auch wirklich hands-on dabei ist.
Also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das jetzt grundsätzlich ein amerikanischer Ingenieur nicht kann und nicht darf. Vom Trend her macht er handwerklich sehr viel weniger als umgekehrt. Man sieht auch die deutschen Ingenieure ständig im Flieger, der amerikanischen sieht man in den Büroräumen. Ich übertreibe jetzt ein bisschen.
Und organisatorisch hat die NASA eine andere Art und Weise, solche Projekte zu managen?
Ja, NASA, glaube ich, hat einen höheren Management und Ingenieuraufwand auf der Design-Ebene. NASA macht sehr viel mit Besprechungen, mit Reviews. In Deutschland macht man vielleicht mehr, dass man eine Zeichnung hernimmt und die Zeichnung kurz erklärt. Dann drückt man in die Hand und wird danach gearbeitet. Bei NASA würde man sich erst mal eine Woche zusammensetzen und die ganzen Details durchgehen, immer wieder besprechen und so weiter. Die Besprechungsintensität auf amerikanischer Seite, um es mal so auszudrücken, ist deutlich höher als in Deutschland zumindest. Ich beobachte so einen Trend, dass das auch hier in Europa bei der ESA so ein bisschen in diese Richtung geht, dass man sich von einer Besprechung zu anderen handelt. Wir hören immer Beschwerden von den Kollegen aus dem Deutschen SOFIA-Institut, die vor Ort arbeiten. Die Hälfte meiner Zeit sitze ich in Besprechungen, in Telefonkonferenzen und komme nicht zum Arbeiten. In meinen Augen ist auch der Personalaufwand auf amerikanischer Seite aus diesem Grund höher. Wir müssen schon ein bisschen auf unsere Kosten achten. Für uns ist es vorteilhaft, dass die Mitarbeiter, die dort entsendet sind, sehr viele Dinge abdecken können. Bei NASA ist es oft so, dass sie sehr gute Fachleute haben, die auf ihrem Gebiet exzellent sind, aber nur auf einem sehr schmalen Bereich. In Deutschland ist das einfach etwas breiter. Der deutsche Ingenieur guckt über seinen Tellerrand ein bisschen hinaus. Er kann Nachbargebiete abdecken. Das trifft natürlich nicht auf jeden Einzelnen zu. Das ist nur so ein allgemeines Statement. Aber das ist nicht auch eine Art der Ausbildung.
Ja, Alois Himmers, ich sage mal vielen Dank für die ausführliche Ausführung zu dem doch sehr interessanten SOFIA Projekt. Da fliegt jetzt schon ein kleines Flugzeug bei mir jetzt im Kopf und versucht immer die richtige Position zu finden. Das wird hier ein sehr interessantes Melange. Auch dieses Jahr beim DLR steht auch ein Titel. Luft- und Raumfahrt kommen jetzt hier auf eine interessante Art und Weise zusammen. Man übernimmt auf einmal Funktionalitäten, die man sonst normalerweise nur jenseits der 100-Kilometer-Marke durchführt. Das lässt sich eben auch mit 10 Kilometern realisieren. Das hat auch ganz andere Implikationen auf den Zyklus, die Geschwindigkeit, die Weiterentwicklung und auch die Nähe zur Ausbildung und Forschung. Aber ich denke, an dieser Stelle können wir es dann auch abschließen.
Ja, das war mir ein Vergnügen. Vielleicht haben Sie mal die Gelegenheit, selber mitzufliegen. Im Moment ist das noch etwas eingeschränkt. Es wird auch später eingeschränkt sein. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel das erste Mal als Reporter mitgeflogen, der Herr Böcke, und er hat auch schon darüber berichtet. Und wenn Sie dann live aus der Stratosphäre berichten, kommt das sicherlich gut an.
Raumzeit-Podcast live aus der Stratosphäre. Na mal schauen, was das hier noch für ein Potenzial birgt. Gut, ja, das war es. Raumzeit, nicht die letzte Episode. Wie soll das anders sein? Hier geht es bald wieder weiter mit dem nächsten interessanten Thema aus dem Universum von ESA und DLR. Ich sag danke fürs Zuhören und tschüss und bis bald.